Hey everybody, make sure to listen after the credits for an exclusive look.
大家好，记得在片尾之后收听我们的独家内容。
Listen, I guess it's more of a listen than a look for the audio book version of my debut novel.
听着，对于我的首部小说的有声书版本来说，与其说是“看”，不如说是“听”。
That's not how it happened.
事情可不是这样的。
It's told from four different perspectives and two of the narrators for the audiobook are none other than Josh Radner and Kobe Smolders.
它从四个不同的视角展开讲述，而有声书的其中两位旁白正是乔什·拉德纳和寇碧·史莫德斯。
And at the end of today's podcast episode, we're going to play an exclusive clip from the book where you'll hear a little bit of Josh and Kobe and it's going to be legend.
在今天播客节目的最后，我们将播放一段书中的独家片段，大家会听到一点乔什和寇碧的声音，这绝对会是传奇般的体验。
Wait for it to the end of the credits.
请坚持听到片尾。
Welcome back to another episode of How We Made Your Mother, where I, Josh Radner, talk about the TV show, How I Met Your Mother, with series co-creator Craig Thomas, hello Craig.
欢迎回到《老爸老妈的浪漫史》幕后揭秘节目，我是乔什·拉德纳，我将与本剧联合主创克雷格·托马斯一起聊聊这部电视剧《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，克雷格，打个招呼吧。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Hey, that's all I got.
嘿，我就这些要说的。
I should say more words.
我应该多说点。
was a pause.
刚才停顿了一下。
I'm excited to be here.
我很高兴能来到这里。
I just didn't want to, I didn't know if you were going to keep talking and let's just keep, now you talk more.
我只是不想……我不知道你还要不要继续说，我们就这样……行了，现在你多说点吧。
You don't seem that excited to be here.
你看起来好像没那么高兴来这儿。
I'm very excited.
我非常高兴。
I love this episode.
我很喜欢这一集。
This is a good one.
这一集很棒。
We got a good one today.
我们今天有一集好内容。
Yeah, we're having a great time.
对，我们玩得很开心。
We're going back through how I made Mother We're already up to the second season, episode three.
我们正在重温《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，我们已经进展到第二季第三集了。
This episode is called brunch.
这一集叫作《早午餐》。
By the way, I started on this show.
顺便说一下，我参演了这部剧。
I played Ted Mosby from 2005 to 2014.
我在2005年到2014年饰演泰德·莫斯比。
Craig co-created the show with Carter Bayes.
克雷格和卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧。
And we're rolling back through it.
我们正在重温它。
My wife has never seen the show.
我妻子从没看过这部剧。
Jordana, my wife.
乔丹娜，我妻子。
So we're watching it.
所以我们在看。
She's a binger.
她是个狂热追剧迷。
She's frustrated.
她很不满。
Both our wives, we learned are frustrated at the slow pace we're having to go.
我们了解到，我们俩的妻子都对我们目前不得不放慢的进度感到不满。
We were talking about this because we have to record certain episodes out of order.
我们之前在聊这个，因为我们得按非正常顺序录制某些剧集。
We literally already did that today.
我们今天 literalmente 刚刚就这么做了。
And my wife refuses to jump ahead.
我妻子拒绝跳着看。
And I think yours says to, we just discovered they both feel this way.
我觉得你妻子也是，我们刚发现她们俩都有这种感觉。
Mostly I'm watching it with my wife.
主要是我在和妻子一起看。
You're definitely watching it with her because the whole, this whole podcast kind of came from her never having seen the show.
你绝对是在和她一起看，因为整个……这个播客的灵感其实就来自于她从未看过这部剧。
And so she's like, I'm not jumping ahead.
所以她总是说，我才不跳着看呢。
And I do respect you.
我确实很尊重你。
She would be infuriated if I watched an episode without her.
如果我背着她看了一集，她会气疯的。
So we're having to watch twice.
所以我们得看两遍。
You and I go to, I'll tell you this.
你和我去……我跟你讲这个。
They go down easy.
它们看起来很轻松。
They do.
确实如此。
They're very watchable.
非常耐看。
They're too short.
它们太短了。
Goddamn it.
该死的。
I wish it was a full fucking half hour.
我真希望它能有整整半小时该死的时长。
Sorry.
抱歉。
I'm sorry, I'm sorry to get there in.
抱歉，很抱歉我爆粗口了。
I wish we had at least, I wanted to be 25 minutes.
我希望我们至少能有，我本来想要25分钟的。
Can it just be 25, can we go back and make it 25 minutes?
能正好是25分钟吗，我们能回去改成25分钟吗？
So this is episode three of season two.
所以这是第二季的第三集。
The episode is called brunch, Alec.
这一集叫早午餐，亚历克。
Give us a little historical context.
给我们讲点历史背景吧。
I will tell you that it was written by Stephen Lloyd and it was released unto the world on October 2nd in the year 2006.
我告诉你，这是由斯蒂芬·劳埃德编写的，并于2006年10月2日向世界发布。
The great Stephen Lloyd, one of the other longest-serving, I like that term because it makes it seem like it's a Supreme Court justice.
伟大的斯蒂芬·劳埃德，任职时间最长的编剧之一，我喜欢这个词，因为这听起来他就像最高法院的大法官一样。
The longest, one of the longest-serving how I met your mother writers.
任职时间最长，《老爸老妈浪漫史》任职时间最长的编剧之一。
Stephen Lloyd had a lifetime appointment to the writer's room of how I met your mother.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德对《老爸老妈浪漫史》编剧室拥有终身任命权。
Joanne de Leibs, part with you, season one, but then went all the way with us.
乔安妮·德·利布斯，第一季和你合作，但随后一直和我们走到最后。
So besides Chris Harris and Courtney Kang, I guess the third longest-serving how much mother writer.
所以除了克里斯·哈里斯和考特尼·康g之外，我想他是任职第三长的《老爸老妈》编剧。
Stephen Lloyd, I think will be delighted I remember this, the reason he was late in joining us was because he was on a show where Pamela Anderson worked in a bookstore and it was called stacked.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德，我想他会很高兴我还记得这件事，他之所以加入我们较晚，是因为他之前在一个节目里工作，帕特里夏·安德森在书店里工作，那个节目叫《书店群英会》。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
Absolutely.
当然记得。
Which, by the way, is a great name for a show about Pamela Anderson, where you have a bookstore.
顺便说一句，对于一个讲帕特里夏·安德森且背景是书店的节目来说，这是一个很棒的名字。
By the way, Pamela Anderson, the documentary about her, which my sisters both urged me to watch, is very moving.
顺便说一句，关于帕特里夏·安德森的那部纪录片，我的两个姐妹都催我去看，非常感人。
Oh, that's cool.
哦，那挺酷的。
I would totally watch that.
我绝对会去看。
I saw her in a Tennessee Williams play and Williams town this summer in the super weird experimental Camino Real like really weird avant-garde like two hour Tennessee William very infrequently produced piece and she was great and she was like part of a really avant-garde super weird theater experience.
今年夏天我在威廉斯敦看过她演的田纳西·威廉斯戏剧，在一个超级古怪的实验性话剧《卡米诺雷亚尔》里，真的非常怪异前卫，是一部时长两小时、很少上演的田纳西·威廉斯作品，她演得很棒，就像是一个真正前卫、超级古怪的戏剧体验的一部分。
The weekend that naked gun came out.
就在《白头神探》上映的那个周末。
So she's promoting naked gun and she was like, listen, I gotta leave my interviews.
所以她当时在宣传《白头神探》，然后她说，听着，我得结束采访了。
I have to go a star in the weirdest fucking Tennessee Williams play at the small college theater.
我得去一个小型大学剧院主演那部他妈的超级古怪的田纳西·威廉斯戏剧。
I think that's incredibly rock star.
我觉得这简直酷毙了。
Pamela Anderson has a big movie coming out and she's like, I'll be in Williams town doing Tennessee Williams if you need me.
帕特里夏·安德森有一部大电影要上映，但她却说，如果你们需要我，我会在威廉斯敦演田纳西·威廉斯。
It was the opening weekend of that movie written by the movie written by Doug and Dan, our two how much mother writers and very funny.
那是那部电影上映的首周末，那部电影是由道格和丹编写的，我们的两个《老爸老妈》编剧，非常搞笑。
And as all that shit was blowing up, I'm texting them and I'm like, how am I seeing Pamela Anderson in the Tennessee Williams, why she's promoting your movie?
就在那些乱七八糟的事闹得沸沸扬扬的时候，我发信息问他们：为什么我能在田纳西·威廉斯的剧里看到帕梅拉·安德森？为什么她在宣传你们的电影？
They're like, yeah, she's cool.
他们说，对啊，她挺酷的。
And I say my favorite line from Naked Gun, which I found to be delightful, by the way.
然后我说了《白头神探》里我最喜欢的一句台词，顺便说一句，我觉得非常妙。
Very funny.
非常搞笑。
Very, very funny.
非常、非常搞笑。
When she says, I came out here for college and Liam Neeson says, UCLA, and she says, I see it every day.
当她说：我来这儿是为了上大学。连姆·尼森说：UCLA（加州大学洛杉矶分校），她却说：我天天都能看见它。
I live here.
我就住在这儿。
I mean, A plus.
我的意思是，简直是A加。
A plus.
A加。
Yeah.
对。
Yes.
是的。
Great work, Doug and Dan.
干得好，道格和丹。
Yeah.
对。
Doug and Dan didn't join us until many seasons.
道格和丹过了很多季才加入我们。
Many seasons hence.
很多季以后。
So Stephen Lloyd, one of the other all-time great how much mother writers hilarious.
还有斯蒂芬·劳埃德，另一位《老爸老妈浪漫史》历史上最伟大的编剧之一，太搞笑了。
He'll be on here.
他也会来这里。
So, thank you, Stephen, for joining us from Stacked.
所以，谢谢斯蒂芬从《宋飞正传》剧组加入我们。
And so, Craig, give us a little summary of what this episode is.
那么，克雷格，给我们简单总结一下这一集讲的是什么吧。
Yeah, so this is the third episode of this new condition where Marshall and Lily are broken up, and this is an episode of mostly about Ted's relationship to his parents, which I love, this idea of being in your 20s and realizing I'm not able to talk to my parents as adults, and they're not being adults in their way of talking to me.
好的，这是马歇尔和莉莉分手后的第三集，这一集主要讲的是泰德与他父母的关系，我很喜欢这种感觉：二十几岁时突然意识到，我无法像成年人一样与父母沟通，而他们在跟我说话时也没有表现出成年人的样子。
And it is Ted's parents visit from Ohio and a lot of stuff comes out about all of the characters trying to interact with Ted's parents and Ted and Robin go through a certain kind of journey of questioning their own early nascent couplehood by looking at Ted's own parents and Ted learns a huge and devastating fact about his parents at the end of the episode.
这一集讲的是泰德的父母从俄亥俄州来拜访，通过所有角色试图与泰德的父母互动，爆出了很多料；泰德和罗宾通过观察泰德的父母，经历了一场对他们刚刚萌芽的恋情产生质疑的心路历程；而且泰德在这一集的结尾得知了一个关于他父母的巨大且令人崩溃的事实。
But the episode is told in this interesting structure where we begin in a very confusing scene, even when even rewatching it with Rebecca, my wife, who had seen the episode, she's like, wait, at the end of episode two, Marshall and Molly, we're kind of on okay terms at the end of that one.
但这一集的叙事结构很有趣，我们从一个非常令人困惑的场景开始，甚至当我跟我看过这集的妻子丽贝卡一起重温时，她还说：等等，在第二集结尾，马歇尔和莉莉（丽莉）在那集结尾时关系不是还挺融洽的吗？
We're literally kind of skunked Barney with that, that ruse about she was twins.
我们差点就被巴尼那场关于她有双胞胎的骗局给忽悠了。
What are they fighting?
他们到底在为什么吵架？
I'm like, wait, wait for it.
我就想，等等，等一下。
We're beginning at the end, it's going to back up.
我们从结局开始，然后倒回前面。
And a lot of shows do the, the, you know, start in a weird in-media rest, kind of in the middle weird scene and then back up up and say 48 hours earlier.
很多剧集都会，你知道的，开局先来一段莫名其妙的倒叙（in media res），搞一段中间的奇怪场景，然后再倒退回去，说“48小时前”。
So we did do that, a lot of shows have done that, and we did that.
所以我们确实这么做了，很多剧都这么干过，我们也这么干了。
What I like about our twist on it is, we do it three times.
我喜欢我们对这种套路的改造是，我们搞了三次。
We back up three different times and reseed the events from three different perspectives.
我们倒回去了三次，从三个不同的视角重新梳理这些事件。
I thought that made it special.
我觉得这让它变得很特别。
Well, there's also an A storyline, B storyline, C storyline, all happening around that table.
嗯，而且那张桌子周围还同时在发生着A线、B线和C线剧情。
Yeah.
对。
And it's cool because it's like, it's I guess the Ted Robin parent story is the A story, but it's like, even though the Marshall and Lily, again, it's like, it's not peripheral.
而且很酷的是，我觉得泰德和罗宾父母的故事是A线，但尽管马修和莉莉的故事，再说一次，它不是边缘化的。
It's like very central to the action, and it's hilarious too, we'll get into all that.
它可以说是整个情节的核心，而且也非常搞笑，我们待会儿会详细聊到。
I do have to say, when you told me, or someone told me, you or Carter, that Michael Gross was going to be playing my father.
我必须得说，当你告诉我，或者有人告诉我，你或卡特说迈克尔·格罗斯要来演我父亲的时候。
Yes.
没错。
The kid in me that grew up in Columbus, Ohio, which by the way.
我内心那个在俄亥俄州哥伦布市长大的孩子——顺便说一句。
We should explain this, explain this all the way, because the youngins that might be listening to this don't even know what we're talking about already.
我们得解释一下，从头到尾解释清楚，因为听这个节目的年轻一代可能根本不知道我们在说什么。
When I was growing up, Thursday night on NBC, This is pre-friends, pre-signfeld.
我长大的时候，NBC的周四晚上，那是《老友记》和《宋飞正传》之前的时代。
Fuck yeah.
靠，没错。
Thursday night on NBC was the greatest night of television.
NBC的周四晚上是电视史上最棒的夜晚。
Cosby Show at eight o'clock, eight 30 family ties, nine o'clock cheers, nine 30 night court, 10 o'clock LA law.
八点是《考斯比一家》，八点半是《结蒂家情》（Family Ties），九点是《欢乐酒店》，九点半是《夜间法庭》，十点是《洛城法律》。
LA law.
《洛城法律》。
Can I just get a shout out to anyone who remembers this, this mighty lineup on television?
我能向所有还记得电视上这个强大阵容的人致敬吗？
You wouldn't miss a moment.
你不会错过任何一刻。
You wouldn't miss one second of that.
你一秒钟都不会错过。
That was three hours of TV.
那是整整三个小时的电视节目。
actually, and I don't mention this very much, but on my sub stack, it's called dead father society.
说实话，我平时不怎么提起这个，但在我的Substack上，有一个栏目叫“死去的父亲协会”。
My father passed away when I was 17.
我父亲在我17岁时去世了。
I've just written a piece that's all about Thursday nights.
我刚写了一篇文章，全都是关于周四晚上的。
It's all about what my dad and I would do.
全都是我和我爸爸以前会做什么。
We would go for pizza and some other stuff, and then we would go home and we would watch those four, maybe five shows.
我们会去吃比萨饼和别的什么，然后回家看那四部，也许五部剧。
Wow.
哇。
So yeah, very, very meaningful night for me as well.
所以对我也一样，这是一个非常有意义的夜晚。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I can't wait to read that, Alec.
我迫不及待想读那篇文章，亚力克。
Everyone should read that.
每个人都该读读。
And that's, I mean, it's hard to explain to people what that was.
而且，我是说，很难向人们解释那意味着什么。
We were in 2025.
我们现在身处2025年。
There's There's kind of the lack of that shared experience, the lack of the campfire we're all sitting around.
那种共同的体验有些缺失了，那种大家围坐在一起的“篝火”不见了。
I think that's...
我觉得那是……
The mono culture.
单一文化。
Yeah.
对。
I think that's a huge problem, sociologically, we won't get into that right now.
我认为从社会学角度来看这是一个巨大的问题，我们现在就不展开聊了。
But we had that, right?
但我们曾经拥有过，对吧？
And Family Ties was really in the center of that family.
而《结蒂家情》真的是那个家庭的核心。
I talk about how Cheers was one of the biggest influences on me as a writer, part of why I wanted to be a comedy writer.
我经常说《欢乐酒店》对我的编剧生涯产生了巨大影响，这也是我想成为一名喜剧编剧的部分原因。
But I don't think I say it often enough that Family Ties was very much up in that conversation.
但我说得可能还不够多，那就是《结蒂家情》也绝对在那个讨论范围内。
I know for Carter, too, who's also from Ohio, talk about a show that was hilarious and and it could also be very moving and complicated and really nuanced, yeah.
我也知道对卡特来说，他也是俄亥俄州人，说到一部既搞笑又能让人感动、情节复杂且极其细腻的剧，就是它了。
Do you know why I know what SCUBA stands for?
你知道为什么我知道SCUBA（水肺）是什么意思吗？
Self-contained underwater breathing apparatus.
自携式水下呼吸器。
Underwater breathing apparatus.
水下呼吸器。
Mallory has a breakthrough study here on that.
马洛里在这方面有一项出色的研究。
Yes, study for the great show.
是的，为了这个伟大的节目做研究。
She's not a great student, absolutely.
她绝对不是个好学生。
Brilliant.
太精彩了。
And so talk about what that meant to you.
那么谈谈这对你意味着什么吧。
It was set in literally where you're from, right?
它故事发生的背景可以说是你的家乡，对吧？
Yeah, it's set in Columbus, Ohio.
对，背景设在俄亥俄州哥伦布市。
What did that feel like when you're at that age and you're watching a TV show be set there?
当你处于那个年龄，看到一部电视剧把背景设在那里，是什么感觉？
Like was that one of those moments said, set you on your path?
这算不算是那些指引你走上人生道路的时刻之一？
Well, yeah, I mean, I watched, it's so funny, I'm not a big TV watcher now, but I was a big TV watcher when I was a kid.
嗯，对，我的意思是，我看过——说来也奇怪，我现在不怎么看电视，但我小时候是个电视迷。
I really loved television and I loved sitcoms, I loved Alice, I, you know, I loved Taxi, I loved, I would watch Barney Miller when there was nothing else, you know?
我真的很喜欢电视，我喜欢情景喜剧，我喜欢《爱丽丝》，你知道的，我喜欢《出租车》，没事的时候我还会看《巴尼·米勒》，你知道吗？
I watched a lot of TV and family ties was probably like pound for pound, my favorite show.
我看了很多电视，《天才家庭》可能是我最喜欢的节目，不相上下。
like just moment to moment delight.
就像每一个瞬间都充满欢乐。
And I think, you know, it was so perfectly cast, there was just such a light touch around it.
而且我认为，你知道，它的演员阵容太完美了，整部剧的处理手法非常轻松。
It's hard to do a family show that is both moving, but not trickly, you know.
要做一部既感人又不做作的家庭剧是很难的，你知道的。
It was a great idea, just for anyone listening who's a little bit younger may not have seen film made eyes.
这是一个很棒的想法，对于任何可能没看过《天才家庭》的年轻听众来说。
First of all, go find it and stream it.
首先，去找来看看并在线播放吧。
I, we don't make any money by plugging that show, but please, it's phenomenal.
我，我们宣传那个节目拿不到一分钱，但拜命大家去看看，它太棒了。
But the premise is, it's these hippie parents, right?
但它的前提是，这是一对嬉皮士父母，对吧？
That we're kind of coming of age in the 60s as these piece love of the front lines of all the marches and protests.
他们在60年代度过青春期，作为反战和平运动的亲历者，走在游行和抗议的最前线。
Right, with wonderful politics, like the wonderfully humanistic politics, like they're just these menchy people and they have a family, they have three kids.
没错，有着极佳的政治立场，就像那种极具人情味的政治立场，他们就是这种正派的人，他们有一个家庭，有三个孩子。
And one of them turns out to be Alex P.
其中一个竟然是亚历克斯·P·
Keaton, which launched Michael J.
基顿，这个角色把迈克尔·J·
Fox into the Stratospheric, who was a genius in that role.
福克斯推向了事业的巅峰，他在那个角色中简直是个天才。
Genius, genius performance.
天才，绝佳的表演。
And he is this young Republican in a suit, I think young Republican in a suit influenced Barney Stinson.
他是一个穿着西装的年轻共和党人，我觉得穿着西装的年轻共和党人影响了巴尼·斯廷森。
Honestly, Carter and I would talk about that sometimes.
老实说，卡特有时会和我谈起这个。
Like I think that's part, that is part of the influence.
我觉得这确实是部分影响所在。
And so it's that idea of parents having a kid and the kid is a little bit of like an alien to them, right?
所以这体现了这样一种理念：父母生了一个孩子，而这个孩子对他们来说有点像个外星人，对吧？
And there are these two sisters too who each have different personality quirks.
家里还有两个姐妹，每个人都有不同的性格怪癖。
Like Mallory's not a great student.
就像马洛里学习不是很好。
Alex is like a double A plus like overachiever, but with this like serious like Ronald Reagan, like obsession, it's just a great, It was a show that talked comedically about family dynamics and politics.
亚历克斯是个全A加的超级优等生，但对罗纳德·里根有一种严重般的痴迷，这真是一个伟大的节目，它以喜剧的方式探讨了家庭动态和政治。
It's almost hard to imagine, right?
几乎很难想象，对吧？
At this moment in 2025 that there could be this show that could just make that okay.
在2025年的当下，居然能有一部剧把这一切处理得如此自然。
Beyond the political stuff, it was really an illustration of whatever you are and whatever you think you're handing off to your kids, they're probably gonna attack the other way.
抛开政治内容不谈，它真正说明了一点：无论你是谁，无论你认为自己传授给孩子什么观念，他们很可能会走向反方向。
Like they're not gonna be carbon copy.
他们不会是你的复制品。
They're their own people.
他们是独立的个体。
And it was so brilliant at that.
这方面的表现真是太出色了。
All of which is to say, this is a long way to say, The Father on that show was played by Michael Gross, who played Ted's Father.
所有这一切都是为了说明，兜了这么大一个圈子想说的是，剧中父亲的扮演者是迈克尔·格罗斯，也就是泰德父亲的扮演者。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我为你写了这段小日程，送你在纽约市使用。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目中。
Now I mentioned going back to yourself, Josh, trying traveling back to past you and saying, that guy's gonna play my dad on TV.
现在我提到回到过去的自己，乔治，试着回到过去的自己，然后对他说，那家伙以后要在电视里演我爸了。
10, 11, 12, 13.
10、11、12、13。
However old I was when I'm watching these shows and it's my favorite show.
无论我看这些节目时我是几岁，它都是我最喜欢的节目。
And then I grow up, I become a professional actor.
然后我长大了，成为了一名专业演员。
I get on this big show and Alex P.
我参演了这部大热剧，而亚历克斯·P·
Keaton's father, the guy who played his father is now playing my father.
基顿的父亲，也就是扮演他父亲的那个人，现在在演我的父亲。
And I don't think Michael, like I don't know that I was able to communicate how important family ties was to me.
而且我觉得迈克尔——我不知道我是否能够表达清楚《天才家庭》对我的重要性。
You know, he's obviously, he's a guest star on now my show, which was trippy and vertigo-inducing.
你知道，他显然现在是我的节目的客串明星，这感觉很不真实，让人目眩神迷。
But definitely.
但绝对是这样的。
But to me, he was just a face and a voice that was emblazoned onto my consciousness in the same way I'm sure I am for other people.
不过对当时的关我而言，他只是一个面孔和声音，深深烙印在我的意识里，就像我相信我也这样印在其他人心里一样。
Yeah.
对啊。
And did you attempt to tell him?
那你尝试告诉过他吗？
Did you dork out on him a little bit?
你在他面前表现得很狂热、很迷弟吗？
Or he was so down to earth, he didn't come in with any kind of ego about it.
还是说他非常脚踏实地，完全没有什么明星架子？
No.
没有。
And it'd been a minute since family ties, even then.
而且即使在那个时候，距离《成长的烦恼》播出也已经过去好一阵子了。
But I was star struck by him for sure.
但我见了他确实感到非常崇拜和震撼。
He still had an easy way about him, both often on screen.
无论在幕前还是幕后，他身上总是有一种随和放松的气质。
He's an actor to me that doesn't push, you know.
对我来说，他是一个演戏从不流于表面的演员，你知道的。
That's right.
没错。
He underplays it, and it plays very real.
他处理得很克制，但演得非常真实。
He's underplaying it, he's pretty relaxed.
他的表演很内敛，而且相当放松。
He's, you know, and he seems like a dad who probably did some things well, and some things not so.
他给人的感觉就像是一个父亲，可能有些事情做得很好，有些事情则不那么完美。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
He, it was just a delight to, I remember in the early seasons of Howie Mary Mother, that was the thing, for some reason, the fact that Michael Gross from Family Ties was playing my father on television, was the strangest thing of all of it.
他……能跟他合作简直是一种享受。我记得在《老爸老妈浪漫史》的前几季里，最不可思议的一点——不知为什么，因参演《成长的烦恼》而走红的迈克尔·格罗斯竟然在电视上扮演我的父亲，这成了整部剧里最奇妙的事情。
I mean, I like the idea of younger you somehow knowing that someday.
我是说，我挺喜欢这种假设的：年轻时的你 irgendwie（不知怎么的）知道自己有一天会……
Like I just, it's mind blowing if you could have somehow known that.
就好像，如果你当时能预知这一切，那真的太让人震撼了。
Now, did you, it is an episode about not communicating in a family, right?
话说回来，这一集讲的是一个关于家庭缺乏沟通的故事，对吧？
Our episode, I mean, all right, right?
我说的是我们这一集，没错吧？
This is an episode where Ted's parents do not know how to talk to him and he does not know how to talk to them.
这一集讲的是泰德的父母不知道该怎么跟他说话，而他也不知道该怎么跟他们沟通。
Did that resonate for you guys, in the writers?
这在你们编剧当中引起共鸣了吗？
Well, I wanna say my parents sometimes listen to this show.
嗯，我想说我的父母有时会收听这个节目。
So I just want to say I love them.
所以我只想说我爱他们。
I love them very dearly.
我非常非常爱他们。
You know, I don't think I had to dig very deep for like parents from Ohio and you kind of want to take them a little deeper and they're, you know, but, you know, it's, I think that that's a generational thing.
你知道，我觉得自己不需要为了塑造来自俄亥俄州的父母而去挖掘多深的体验，而且你多少会想让他们显得更立体一点，他们呢……但你知道，我觉得这是一种代际现象。
Like I've talked about this with my father.
就像我跟我父亲聊过这个。
Like I think my parents and I have different love languages.
我觉得我和我父母有不同的爱的表达方式。
Like there's not a button that my mom will not sew onto a shirt for me.
比如说，我妈没有什么纽扣是不会帮我缝到衬衫上的。
There's not a shirt she won't iron.
没有什么衬衫是她不肯熨的。
there's not a creamer that I don't want that's not in the refrigerator or would I get home.
没有哪个我想要的咖啡伴侣是我一回家冰箱里没有的。
My dad, I had this lawsuit on this patio that's gone on for years.
至于我爸，我为了这个露台的法律纠纷已经持续了好几年。
It's thankfully my God coming to a close, but my dad gave me hundreds of hours of free legal advice and counsel on this thing.
谢天谢地，上帝保佑，这件事快要结束了，但为此我爸给了我几百个小时的免费法律建议和咨询。
And if they see key lime pie on the menu, they'll pick it up and it'll be in the fridge when I get, you know what I mean?
而且如果他们看到菜单上有青柠派，他们就会买下来，等我回家时它就会静静躺在冰箱里，你知道我的意思吗？
Like there's different ways to love and communicate.
这就是不同的爱和沟通方式。
And I'm really into words of affirmation and deep communication, and sometimes that's been like a struggle or a navigation.
而我本人非常热衷于肯定的话语和深入的交流，有时候这确实是一种挣扎或需要摸索的过程。
Like I always kind of want to lure them into more open communication.
比如我总是想引导他们进行更开放的沟通。
So I don't think I had to dig that deep for this part of that, you know?
所以我认为，为了演好这一部分，我不需要挖掘得太深，你懂的？
Yeah, well, the writer's room certainly didn't.
对啊，编剧室里的其他人当然也不需要。
The writer's room definitely Carter's also from Ohio.
编剧室里的人绝对……卡特也是来自俄亥俄州。
And, you know, like, I think there's some similarities or like- There's a kind of Midwestern stoicness that, you know, it's a real thing.
而且，你知道，我觉得有些相似之处，或者说……有一种中西部式的隐忍，你知道的，这确实存在。
But it's in my, I'm from Long Island There's plenty of that in my Irish Catholic rooted family too.
不过在我身上——我是从长岛来的——在我这个爱尔兰天主教根基的家庭里，也有很多这种特质。
So I think a lot, the comedy writers in that room, I'll have a lot to draw on.
所以我觉得编剧室里的那些喜剧编剧们，都有很多可以取材的地方。
This was not a hard episode to tell from the writers.
对于编剧们来说，写这一集并不是什么难事。
You know, sometimes I think it's not a matter of, like the kid assumes, oh, they don't really want to talk to me or they're not interested in my interior life.
你知道，有时候我觉得这并不是说——就像小孩子以为的那样，“哦，他们其实根本不想跟我说话”或者“他们对我的内心世界不感兴趣”。
But the truth is, if you really get honest, you're all just gonna break down in a puddle of tears saying, I love you, I want you to be safe.
但事实是，如果你真的足够坦诚，你们最后都会哭成一团，嘴里说着“我爱你，我希望你平平安安”。
Like, that's what's underneath it.
这才是这一切背后的实质。
Yeah, and I like in the end of this episode, Ted gets finally some honesty out of his parents.
对，我挺喜欢这一集的结尾，泰德终于从他父母那里得到了一些真诚的话。
It's a nice moment, but I also like the twist that some of the honesty cast a few doubts and like, oh wait, some of these other dynamics between Ted and Robin in this new relationship, trying to figure it out, and that was kind of a funny extra little twist.
这是个不错的时刻，但我也很喜欢那个转折：那些坦诚的话语也带来了一些质疑，比如“哦等等，泰德和罗宾在这段新关系中的其他动态，他们还在努力摸索”，这其实是一个挺有趣的额外小转折。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
But they were so great.
不过他们演得太棒了。
Christine Rose, fantastic, she did a lot at the show.
克里斯蒂娜·罗斯，太棒了，她在剧里贡献了很多精彩表演。
She did a bunch, she did, yeah.
她演了很多，确实演了很多，对。
but she was never not hilarious.
但她每一次出场都 hilarious（滑稽爆笑）。
Like she was never not like kind of perfectly patrician and kind of like, she was just fantastic.
就好像她总是带着一种完美的高贵气质，而且有点……她简直太棒了。
Just changing the subject when everything's got uncomfortable.
每当气氛变得尴尬时，她就直接转移话题。
She underplayed things too in a really subtle great way.
她对角色的处理也很克见功力，用一种非常微妙而精妙的方式。
Like when she had a great joke with Robin where Robin flirts out, I'm not ready, which she says, Robin what's it like being a Newscaster?
就像她和罗宾有一段很棒的笑话，罗宾脱口而出“我还没准备好”，她却说：“罗宾，当新闻主播是什么感觉？”
And Robin says, I'm not ready.
然后罗宾说：“我还没准备好。”
And she's like, okay, we'll take your time.
接着她说：“好吧，那我们慢慢来。”
Like she just like, she sits with that.
就好像她把这句话给接住了。
Like she's very funny.
她真的非常搞笑。
You know, drawing back on the generational differences among parents and kids, like family ties, the parent, Ted's parents undergo in some ways a second adolescence and he's like the adult.
你知道，回过头来看看父母和孩子之间的代际差异，就像在《成长的烦恼》里，父母、泰德的父母在某种程度上经历了第二次青春期，而反而是他像个成年人。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
In a lot of ways, you know, in this episode and in future episodes with the mother too.
在很多方面都是如此，你知道，在这集里，以及后来有母亲出场的剧集里也是。
Yeah, it's really funny.
对，这真的很有趣。
Like you see that little glimpse of Ted as a dad and that's also a thing, right?
就像你看到了泰德作为父亲的惊鸿一瞥，这也是一种情况，对吧？
Where you start to, you're the adult and you start to see your parents' foibles and that they're childlike in their own ways and that starts to switch over time.
当你开始成长为成年人，你就会开始看到父母身上的缺点，看到他们在某些方面其实还像个孩子，这种角色转换随着时间推移就开始发生了。
You know, I was just talking with Jordana about this.
你知道，我刚好在和乔丹娜聊这件事。
There's something really smart.
这里面有一个非常聪明的设计。
There's a little, there's a time bomb placed inside of Ted and Robin's relationship in this episode, which is the idea, I think when you're in your 20s, you really have a belief that love will conquer all.
在这一集里，泰德和罗宾的关系中埋下了一个定时炸弹，那就是这种观念：我觉得当你处于二十多岁的时候，你真的坚信爱情能够战胜一切。
Like all you need is love and chemistry and connection.
就像你需要的只有爱、化学反应和心灵连接。
And the truth is a long-term relationship.
但事实是，一段长期关系……
Esther Perelle, I don't know if she coined this, which she says there's a difference between a love story and a life story.
艾丝瑟·培瑞尔——我不知道这是不是她发明的概念——她说过，爱情故事和生活故事之间是有区别的。
That's a great line.
这真是一句金句。
And I really like that distinction.
我真的很喜欢这种区别。
You know, like, not every love story is gonna turn into a life story.
你知道的，并不是每一段爱情故事都能变成生活故事。
Yeah.
对啊。
And I think that, you know, it's so easy to roll your eyes at the earlier generations advice and what they've learned along the way.
而且我觉得，我们太容易对老一辈的建议以及他们一路上学到的经验嗤之以鼻了。
But then you get to be that age and you go, oh, you know, my parents really had a point about that.
但等你到了那个年纪，你就会想：“哦，原来我父母当年说得真有道理。”
Or, you know, and Jordana was talking about, you know, this couple that she knew in their twenties who just couldn't have been hotter for each other, more in love, and it's not like that anymore, like finances got in the way, and kids, there's just certain things that the bombs went off a little bit, they're still together, by the way, this couple, but I think that there's, this is a really good example of, and this might sound cynical, but you need a touch more than love.
或者，你知道的，乔丹娜曾提起过一对她认识的二十多岁情侣，他们当时爱得死去活来，感情炽热无比，但现在却物是人非了——柴米油盐的经济压力介入了，还有孩子，总有些特定的事情让定时炸弹引爆了一点。顺便说一句，这对情侣现在还在一起，但我觉得，这是一个非常好的例子——这听起来可能有点愤世嫉俗，但除了爱，你还需要更多一点别的东西。
you have to be aligned in terms of what you want your future to look like, where your values are.
你们必须在对未来的期望以及人生价值观上保持高度一致。
And timing really matters.
而且时机真的很重要。
And time, are you in the same place at the same time?
时间和时机：你们是否在对的时间遇到了对的人？
Oh, it might be the most important thing is the time.
哦，时机可能才是最重要的事情。
Yeah, yeah, and that's what Ted and Robin piece in this episode, you sense the timing does not align and there is a certain.
对，对，这也是泰德和罗宾在这一集里面对的问题，你能感觉到他们的时机并不对盘，并且存在着某种……
I do love how this episode really starts with a mystery.
我很喜欢这一集其实是以一个谜团开场的。
Yeah, what's happening?
对，到底发生什么了？
All these jagged edges, like what is going on?
所有这些尖锐的矛盾，到底是怎么回事？
And then you rewind and you get the whole thing.
然后剧情倒叙，让你了解了事情的全貌。
It's so smart.
这真的太聪明了。
This is quite literally Pulp Fiction.
这简直就是《低俗小说》。
It's a very Pulp Fiction-influenced, our white whale guest is Quentin Tarantino, Quentin, if you're listening, please come do this podcast.
这是一部深受《低俗小说》影响的剧，我们梦寐以求的客串嘉宾是昆汀·塔伦蒂诺——昆汀，如果你在听的话，请来上这个播客吧。
Please, Quentin, please, we'd love to chat with you.
拜托了，昆汀，求你了，我们很想和你聊聊。
He's one of the hugest influences.
他是影响最深远的人之一。
It's basically how much of others a Pulp Fiction meets family ties.
这基本上可以说是《低俗小说》遇上了《成长的烦恼》。
Let's see, that's the quick log line.
你看，这就是简短的电梯演讲（创意梗概）。
What a pitch that CBS buys.
CBS会买账的创意提案就是这样！
But it really is, it has this feeling of like zooming in, zooming in, zooming in, zooming in on a photograph and finding new crucial details, new crucial evidence.
但它确实有那种感觉，就像在一张照片上不断地放大、放大、放大、放大，然后发现了新的关键细节、新的关键证据。
But it starts with this giant wide chaotic shot of what the fuck is going on here.
但它以一个巨大、广阔而混乱的镜头开场，也就是这到底是怎么回事。
Why are Marshall and the lady each other's throats?
为什么马歇尔和那位女士要掐死对方？
Like I said, my wife is actually confused by it even now.
就像我说的，直到现在我妻子其实都对它感到困惑。
And then rewatch you have a sudden right.
然后重看时你突然……对吧。
You wee back up and we show how they got to that point.
我们倒退回去，然后展示他们是如何走到那一步的。
And another thing I love about this episode is it's one of my favorite things is when we see Barney's neediness.
关于这集我喜欢的另一件事，也是我最喜欢的事情之一，就是当我们看到巴尼的需求感时。
And you see the guy under the suit.
你看到了西装底下的那个人。
You see the, you see Anakin Skywalker as he, as when the helmet finally comes off.
你看到了，当头盔终于摘下来时，你看到了天行者安纳金。
Barney wants to be a better, more beloved partner to Ted than Ted's girlfriend.
巴尼想要成为一个比泰德的女友更好、更受喜爱的泰德的伴侣。
And that is the funniest fucking drive.
而这简直是搞笑至极的驱动力。
There's this little moment between you and Neil.
你和尼尔之间有这么一个小小的瞬间。
And some of you guys would have these little throw away moments and that I loved where Barney is explaining.
你们这些家伙会有些这种我特别喜欢的不经意的随性时刻，当时巴尼在解释。
Well, you know, last night I actually left your father early from the bar cause I was drinking with your father and but I had to get home early cause I had to wake up early to go to a mass with your mother and you'd just go, sure.
嗯，你知道的，昨晚其实我让我爸从酒吧早退了，因为我在和你爸喝酒，但我不得不早点回家，因为我得早起去陪你妈做弥撒，而你就会说，好吧。
Just like Ted, Ted, yes ending Barney's ridiculous as sure.
就像泰德那样，泰德，没错，用一个“好吧”结束了巴尼的荒谬言论。
Yeah, that makes sense.
对，这说得通。
Sometimes I loved one word sentences just like that you could throw away like, yeah, cause those play really well on television.
有时我就喜欢那种一句话的句子，就像你可以随口说出的那样，比如“好吧”，因为这些在电视上效果非常好。
Go on.
说下去。
Sure.
好吧。
Yeah, that part of I'm with you.
对，这部分……我懂你。
I'm with you.
我懂你。
But it's also like, it's like a fish floating by and he's like, that fish, I'm not gonna grab that.
但这也有点像，就像一条鱼从旁边游过去，然后他心想，那条鱼，我才不去抓呢。
Like, I'm just gonna let that one go.
就像，我打算就让它过去。
Like, there's other things that I'm gonna have to deal with.
就像，还有其他事情我要去处理。
That is a fantastic metaphor.
这是一个绝妙的比喻。
I will just let you were at Mass with my mom this one.
我就会顺着说，你居然跟我妈一起做弥撒，就这件。
There's a lot of fish with Barney.
巴尼身边的鱼可真不少。
You can't grab every fish with Barney.
你不可能抓住巴尼身边的每一条鱼。
You can't grab everyone.
你不可能每条都抓。
Okay, let's just keep going.
好吧，我们继续吧。
Yeah, so this episode starts with a mystery.
对，所以这集是以一个谜团开场的。
I just want to shout out one of Jason Seagull's line readings that I remember made me laugh maybe the heart it like what is the top five for me is this role is really spicy.
我只想大赞一下杰森·席格尔的一句台词念白，我记得那句让我笑得最厉害，大概能排进我的前五名，就是这个肉卷真的很辣。
When he's just really spicy, he's playing that he's losing his voice from all of the spice on the roll.
当他表现得真的很辣时，他演的是他的嗓子因为肉卷上的所有辣味而开始失声。
It's his throat is constricting from the spice on the piece of bread.
他的喉咙因为那块面包上的辣味而收紧。
But the fact that a brunch breakfast roll would be incredibly spicy.
但早午餐早餐卷居然会辣得不可思议，这个事实。
Just covered in cayon pepper.
上面全覆盖了卡宴辣椒粉。
So Lily is kind of getting dolled up and tempting him sexually, just to be clear.
所以雷切尔其实是在精心打扮，并在性吸引上诱惑他，为了把话说清楚。
But he brings out the big guns.
但他拿出了杀手锏。
Where did Marshall's calves come where did that come from that from from total absurdity I don't know we just thought you know what it was we knew a guy at one point who was like a very um it was a comedy writer who's very muscular and it was just very rare for a comedy writer and when he would get hot in the writer's room if from an earlier show we worked on he would unzip his pants in that way he would have those zip away pants yeah yeah and we're just like that's just very interesting that you have the zip of these legs come off and the zip of light pants become shorts and we're always like that's only like a really like a really in shape like like very confident guy would would be like you got to be proud of your your your calves and shins you got to be proud of the calf shin combo and we're like getting into the mindset of like who who is like let me just let me let me break out the big guns these calves and they're just the act of unzipping your lower pant half leg there was something about that we were all laughing about and we thought what if that for whatever for a reason, what if that's Lily's kind of fetish?
马歇尔的小腿是从哪儿来的？这到底是怎么来的？这源于彻底的荒诞。我不知道，我们当时就想，你知道那是什么吗？我们曾经认识的一个家伙，他是一个非常……呃，他是一个喜剧编剧，非常肌肉发达，这在喜剧编剧里非常罕见，当他在我们之前参与的一部剧的编剧室里觉得热时，他会以那种方式解开裤子，他会有那种拉链可拆卸的裤子，对，对，然后我们就觉得，把这些腿拉链拉开、拉链裤变成短裤，这真的太有意思了，我们总是觉得，只有那种身材非常好、非常自信的家伙才会觉得……你得为你自己的小腿和胫骨感到骄傲，你得为小腿胫骨组合感到骄傲，我们当时就在揣摩这种心态，比如谁会说“让我来，让我……让我亮出杀手锏，就是这些小腿”，而仅仅是解开下半截裤腿这个动作，这就有些让我们全都笑喷了的东西，我们就在想，如果因为某种原因，如果这也是莉莉的一种恋物癖呢？
But there's also like the longer you're in a relationship, there are certain things about a person, whether it's a personality quirk or a physical attribute, that do become like weirdly aphrodisiacal.
但这也像是，你谈恋爱的时间越长，关于一个人，无论是性格怪癖还是身体特征，有些东西确实会变得像怪异的春药一样。
Is that the word?
是这个词吗？
I think you just coined it.
我觉得你刚造了这个词。
Like Jordana is obsessed with my earlobes.
就像乔丹娜对我的耳垂着迷一样。
Now, a lot of people have commented on, I have very Buddha like hanging low earlobes.
现在，很多人都评论过，我有非常像佛祖那样下垂的耳垂。
I'm telling you three times an episode where you're watching, show girl, look at those lobes.
我跟你说，你在看剧的时候，一集里会有三次，瞧瞧那些耳垂。
Oh my God, that's the best.
哦天哪，这太棒了。
You found the right woman, Josh Rader.
你找对人了，乔什·拉德纳。
Congratulations, a muscle show.
恭喜你，肌肉秀。
It's her thing.
这是她的菜。
It's Marshall's calves, my lobes are Marshall's calves.
这就是马歇尔的小腿，我的耳垂就是马歇尔的小腿。
See, so it is, so we invented this a little bit, but it is a thing.
看吧，所以就是这样，虽然我们稍微发明了这个说法，但这确实是一回事。
You want to find that person who has an unreasonable obsession with it, by the way, you have very lovely ear lobes.
你想找到那个对它有着不合理迷恋的人，顺便说一句，你的耳垂非常可爱。
I mean, you know, I'm not downplaying it, but I'll be sure down a, you like that sort of thing.
我是说，你知道的，我不是在淡化它，但我肯定会说……你喜欢那种东西。
But there, you also probably at that point knew Jason and the rest of us enough to know that when Jason unveiled his calves, his punters legs, you knew that he would, that is like, you didn't have to step in and go, okay, do it like this.
但你在那个时候，可能也足够了解杰森和我们其他人，知道当杰森展露他的小腿、他的胖子腿时，你很清楚他会……你不需要介入并说“嘿，就这样做”。
Like you knew Jason is going to lean in.
就像你知道杰森会全力以赴。
He's going to lean in.
他会全力以赴。
That's the greatest, that's the greatest thing about the whole cast of how much mother it's like, no one's going to come and be like, I'm not going to do that.
那是整个《老爸老妈浪漫史》演员阵容中最棒、最棒的一点，那就是没有人会跑过来说“我才不要那样做”。
That's too where he goes like, yeah, this is fucking stupid.
那太……他会说：“好吧，这特么太蠢了。”
and I will lean in to the two at 100%.
而我会百分之百地投入其中。
It was like the more ridiculous, the more you were looking forward to it.
这就好像越荒谬，你就越期待它。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And it got to, it led to the line, take off the rest of your pants from Lily and then coming in the bathroom, which I think that was just a thing of beauty.
这也催生出了一句台词，莉莉说的“脱掉你剩下的裤子”，然后走进浴室，我觉得那简直堪称完美。
I do want to give a shout out to Noel True, who played the waitress who took the photograph was a year ahead of me at NYU.
我确实想向诺尔·特鲁致敬，饰演那个拍照的服务员的那位，她比我在纽约大学高一届。
I'm ace.
我是王牌。
And I was delighted to see her on set that day.
那天在片场看到她我很高兴。
Yeah.
对。
So when Barney enters his first entrance, he walks in and I noticed that Neil, it looks like Barney is expecting a plus.
所以当巴尼完成他的第一次出场时，他走了进来，我注意到尼尔，看起来巴尼在期待掌声。
And it led to a very meta question I have.
这也引发了我一个非常元叙事的问题。
Was Barney the only character who knew he was in a sitcom?
巴尼是唯一一个知道自己身处情景喜剧中的角色吗？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
I think Barney knows he's in a sitcom.
我觉得巴尼知道自己在一部情景喜剧里。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
Everyone else doesn't know.
其他所有人都不知道。
Like all of those philosophical debates of the are we in a simulation, Barney was convinced we were in a sitcom and he was he walked in and you can see it he's expecting entrance applause and he looks at the fourth wall he looks at the fourth wall he looks where the audience would be he's like I'm a beloved character on a sitcom and I'm making my entrance and people should be cheering whereas I Ted thought he was in an independent film I always said Ted was an indie film character who was dropped into a sitcom but he still thought he was in an indie film he was like gunning for Sundance Ted absolutely and that's why that's why it It worked.
就像所有关于“我们是否在模拟世界中”的哲学辩论一样，巴尼确信我们在一部情景喜剧里，他走了进来，你能看出来，他期待着入场掌声，他看着第四堵墙，他看着第四堵墙，他看着观众应该在的地方，他心想“我是情景喜剧里备受喜爱的角色，我正在出场，人们应该为我欢呼”，而相比之下，泰德觉得自己是在拍独立电影，我一直说泰德是一个被扔进情景喜剧里的独立电影角色，但他仍然觉得自己是在拍独立电影，他一心冲着圣丹斯电影节去，泰德绝对是这样的，所以这就是为什么……这就是为什么它行之有效。
That's why their weird chemistry worked, because that is kind of Neil's a little bit more of that, and you're a little bit more of that, too.
这就是为什么他们奇怪的化学反应行之有效，因为尼尔多少有点那种特质，你其实也有一点那种特质。
Like, Neil's a showman, and you're like, I'm gonna go right in direct in D-films, and Neil's gonna go do a musical on Broadway.
就像，尼尔是个表演型人格，而你会说“我要直接去拍独立电影”，尼尔则会去百老汇演音乐剧。
And you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It's like, it worked.
就像，这行得通。
It's okay.
没关系的。
I think far enough is he's in a show.
我觉得巴尼的理解是，他在一个节目里。
He knows he's in a show.
他知道自己在节目里。
Neil was playing it that way in a genius meta way.
尼尔是以一种天才般的元叙事方式来演绎这一点的。
I think he really was.
我觉得他真的是这样。
It really made me laugh, because I was like, he might've even said, like, I'm gonna hold for entrance supply.
这真的让我大笑，因为我想，他甚至可能说过类似“我要为入场掌声停顿一下”的话。
Yeah, I think he did.
对，我觉得他确实说过。
I think he was like, I'm gonna do that bit.
我觉得他当时的想法是“我要演那个包袱”。
And I mean, going back to those 80s shows, there would be applause breaks for those characters and the actors would have to hold.
我的意思是，回到那些80年代的节目，那些角色都会有掌声停顿，演员们必须等着。
When Lenny and Squiggy walked in, they got applause.
当兰尼和斯奎吉走进来时，他们得到了掌声。
They'd wait to talk in the scene.
他们会等掌声停了再在场景中说话。
And there would be, there's no reason in real life why you would wait to talk, but they were waiting.
而且本该如此，在现实生活中你没有任何理由等别人说完了再开口，但他们当时就在等。
I love when Barney said, there's a story behind that broaching.
我太喜欢巴尼说的那句了：“那件胸针背后可有个故事呢。”
I'm gonna hear it.
我一定要听听。
Stephen Lloyd as a writer.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德作为编剧。
We talk about like, just each writer has their quirks.
我们谈到过，每个编剧都有他们的怪癖。
So that just feels like a very Stephen Lloyd line.
所以这听起来非常符合斯蒂芬·劳埃德的风格。
He just has, he is just very, very smart, funny writer, and, but also trend, trends a little dark, like some of the times in the best possible.
他就是那种非常、非常聪明、有趣的编剧，但同时，在最好的情况下，他的风格也带有一点黑暗色彩。
He's the sweetest guy in the world, but he has a hilariously dark sense of humor.
他是世界上最温柔的人，但他有着搞笑的黑暗幽默感。
Did Stephen Lloyd write the one with the murder room?
斯蒂芬·劳埃德写过那个有谋杀室的剧集吗？
Yeah.
对。
I mean, I forget if he, he, it was his pitch, the murder room pitch where I forget at the moment who wrote that specific script.
我的意思是，我忘了那是谁的桥段了，是那个谋杀屋的桥段，我不记得当时是谁写的那个特定剧本。
And you read Stephen Lloyd's script, there's always at least one or two very troubling back story jokes, like Robins, Robins relative in the bell tower.
你读斯蒂芬·劳埃德（Stephen Lloyd）的剧本时，里面总会有一两个非常烦人的背景故事笑话，比如罗宾的亲戚在钟楼里的那个。
Oh, that's the darkest joke in the episode.
哦，那是整集里最黑暗的笑话。
That's one of the dark jokes in the series.
那是整部剧里最黑暗的笑话之一。
And there's at least one or two others in here where you're like, there's a very convoluted dark backstory related to family.
这里面至少还有一两个这样的笑话，你会觉得：有一个与家庭有关的、非常盘根错节的黑暗背景故事。
Stephen Lloyd loves like, Stephen Lloyd, since how much a mother has written a really fun dark horror novel that people should go check out called Friend of the Devil and he's hilariously funny and he has this ability to go dark that is very gothic and it's always perfectly worded.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德很喜欢……斯蒂芬·劳埃德，既然他妈妈写了一本非常有趣的黑暗恐怖小说，大家应该去看看，叫《恶魔之友》（Friend of the Devil），而且他超级搞笑，他有一种能把风格变得非常哥特、非常黑暗的能力，而且措辞总是完美无缺。
It always feels like something out of a very dark play, like a Eugene O'Neill or Arthur Miller.
感觉总是像是出自一部非常黑暗的戏剧，比如尤金·奥尼尔（Eugene O'Neill）或阿瑟·米勒（Arthur Miller）的作品。
There's always like- skeletons in the closet maybe literally in the closet.
总是有那种——衣橱里的秘密，说不定字面意思上就真的在衣橱里。
Yeah, it's very funny.
对，太好笑了。
Do you know what made me laugh?
你知道什么让我笑出来吗？
You remember how in in drum roll, please, we're like, Oh, I guess Ted plays piano.
你还记得在《请敲鼓》（Drumroll, Please）里，我们当时就想，哦，我猜泰德会弹钢琴吧。
Right.
没错。
And now it's like, I guess Barney also is excellent at the piano player.
现在则是：我猜巴尼也是个钢琴演奏高手。
I like the moment that that a scene blow, what did we call a common reader speak a blow up a scene the last joke of every little scene.
我喜欢那个瞬间，就是那个——我们管这个叫什么来着，普通读者管这叫“高潮场景”还是引爆一个场景？就是每一个小场景的最后一个笑话。
It's not that every joke ends every scene ends that way, but it going out on a joke.
并不是每个笑话都会以这种方式结束，也不是每个场景都这样收尾，但它是以一个笑话作为结尾的。
One of the jokes is just Barney going, oh, a piano.
其中一个笑话就是巴尼说了一句：“哦，一架钢琴。”
And that's only a joke because we saw him playing amazing piano in one of the earlier flashbacks.
这之所以算个笑话，仅仅是因为我们在之前的某个闪回里看到他弹过惊艳的钢琴。
So it made me laugh to see a day of like, oh, that was the moment when he decided to go show that he's also an amazing piano player.
所以看到这一幕让我笑出来，心想：哦，这就是他决定去展现自己也是个惊艳的钢琴演奏者的那个时刻。
I really liked also when Barney was with the way Neil did the reading.
我也很喜欢尼尔（Neil）念台词的那种方式。
I'm really not planning these things.
我真的不是在计划这些。
They just keep happening, whatever that was.
它们就是一直在发生，诸如此类的话。
You know that one.
你知道那个的。
Yes, that little like giggly kind of like goat laugh like he does.
对，那种咯咯的、有点像山羊笑的笑声，就像他经常做的那样。
Yeah.
对。
There's so much about Neil's performance of Barney that is deeply controlled and premeditated in a very theatrical and pleasing way.
尼尔对巴尼的演绎中，有很大一部分是经过深度控制和预谋的，具有非常强的戏剧性和讨人喜欢的效果。
But there's also these moments where he gets delighted by himself as a person and as a scheming, whatever he's doing.
但也有一些时刻，他因为自己这个人、因为他那些阴谋诡计或者正在做的事而感到无比开心。
He's the star of his own sitcom, in his own mind.
在他自己的脑海里，他就是他自己的情景喜剧的主角。
Yeah, and it's funny how he's sometimes the funniest when it's not about women, when it's about status when it's about becoming Ted's best friend.
对，而且有趣的是，有时候他最好笑的时刻不是关于女人的，而是关于地位的，是关于如何成为泰德最好的朋友的。
Yeah.
对。
This is status, right?
这就是地位，对吧？
This is because often he's competing with Marshall to be Ted's best friend and always losing.
这是因为他经常与马歇尔竞争成为泰德最好的朋友，而且总是输。
Barney is the Washington Generals against the Globetrotters of Marshall in that French of competition.
在这场竞争中，巴尼就像是迎战马歇尔这个“哈林环球旅行者队”的华盛顿将军队。
And here I really enjoyed his competing with Robin.
而在这里，我真的很享受他和罗宾的竞争。
Ron's like, what is this?
罗宾就像是：这是什么？
What's happening here?
这到底是怎么回事？
Why do you need to be this important to Ted's his parents, but he just, again, and it makes Ted important, I think.
为什么你非得在泰德和他父母眼里这么重要？但他就是这样，而且这再次让泰德显得很重要，我觉得。
It doesn't make Ted the star of the show because Barney just wants to be important to Ted and that extends to his parents.
这并没有让泰德成为节目的主角，因为巴尼只是想对泰德重要，而这种重要性延伸到了他的父母身上。
I would say it's one of Barney's deepest series drives from Pilot on, I just want to know I'm important to Ted.
可以说这是巴尼从第一季开始最深层的驱动力之一：我只想知道我对泰德很重要。
Yeah.
对。
Well, it's also, it's, it's in a weird way, it's him as like a brutal capitalist.
嗯，这也是，用一种奇怪的方式，他就像一个残酷的资本主义者。
Like he doesn't believe that everyone can be a winner.
就像他不相信人人都能成为赢家。
Right.
没错。
Like he doesn't believe like all rising tide lifts all boats.
就像他不相信“水涨船高”那一套。
Like he doesn't believe.
就像他不相信。
Not at all.
一点也不。
He's like, there's gonna be someone left at the end, triumphant standing atop these corpses, atop this funeral pyre, and it's gonna be me, you know?
他觉得：最后总会有一个人留下来，洋洋得意地站在这些尸体上、站在这个火葬堆上，而那个人会是我，你知道吗？
Yes, absolutely.
是的，完全如此。
And hopefully Ted will be with me.
而且希望泰德能跟我在一起。
And Rama says, are you trying to steal Ted from me?
而罗宾则说：你是在试图从我身边把泰德抢走吗？
Like what's happening here?
这到底是怎么回事？
There's a bunch of episodes where he is like, he's really trying to steal, he's really trying to like win Ted from whatever woman he's with.
有很多集里，他都表现得像是——他真的在试图把泰德抢走，真的在试图从泰德身边的任何女人那里把泰德“赢”过来。
Yeah, he is, he just wants to be important to Ted.
对，他就是这样，他只想对泰德重要。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you were sitting.
而那个老头，他……爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里。
And now, commercials!
好了，广告时间！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼（Alex Goldman），《超级纠结》（Hyper-Fixed）播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的烦恼并试着帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，但害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者：为什么当我挂倒档时，不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《超级纠结》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 收听。
End of commercials?
广告结束？
Back to Shell.
回到节目。
Is this the debut of 83% as the faux statistic?
这是“83%”作为虚假统计数据的首次亮相吗？
Yeah, I think so.
对，我想是的。
I think it, yeah, I think it is.
我想它，对，我想是的。
There may have been one other mention of it now that I think of it, but I think it's the First, it's a debut of we decided to call it out and then commit to it for the next seven, eight years.
现在回想起来，可能之前还有过一次提及，但我觉得这是第一次，这是我们决定把它拿出来用，然后在此后的七八年里一直坚持下去的开始。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It is the perfect, were you on Letterman's writing staff when they did top 10 numbers, one through 10?
这简直完美，大卫·莱特曼（Letterman）做1到10的“十大排行榜”时你在他的编剧团队吗？
No, that was like, that was early like NBC version of the show.
没有，那是，那是该节目早期NBC版本的时期。
Okay.
好吧。
Genius, like metal that we wouldn't have done that on the CBS show that was supposed to be reaching a fair audience.
真是天才，像那种疯狂的风格——我们不会在CBS那个旨在触及广泛受众的节目里那样做。
This was like the mad scientist version.
这就像是疯狂科学家的版本。
This was when it was still like, when it was like Conan, like the weirdo culture numbers between one through 10.
这还是在它像柯南（Conan）那种时期，充满1到10之间的怪异文化数字。
And also they just read them like confidently like without any explanation.
而且他们读这些数字时信心十足，没有任何解释。
I'm sure I played to Dead Silence to be confused and to be the best top 10 list ever.
我敢肯定，这引发了一片死寂，让人感到困惑，从而成为史上最佳的十大排行榜。
Yeah.
对。
But 83% feels to me like, for whatever reason, if you were gonna have a guy who just threw out bullshit statistics all the time, 83% is the perfect number.
但“83%”给我的感觉是，无论出于什么原因，如果你要塑造一个满嘴胡说八道统计数据的家伙，“83%”就是最完美的数字。
Like 82% is wrong and 84% is wrong.
因为82%不对，84%也不对。
And I can't explain why.
我也说不出为什么。
What is that?
这是怎么回事？
I know, I'm sure we talked about it at length and arrived at 83 as it's perfect.
我懂，我确信我们曾深入讨论过，最后得出结论：83%就是最完美的。
It's like enough of like an almost be, it's like a BB mine.
它就像是一个差不多能达到的数字，就像是一颗气枪铅弹。
Like it's like enough of what he's trying to prove that it's statistically probable.
它刚好达到了他试图证明的那种具有统计学可能性的程度。
Any lower it wouldn't be convincing and any higher it's unrealistic.
再低一点就没有说服力了，再高一点就不切实际了。
And he knows that intuitively.
而他凭直觉就知道这一点。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
He feels that.
他能感觉到。
He has to hit that number.
他必须击中这个数字。
It's the universal number, it's Fitzpye, it's whatever the...
这是个通用的数字，它是……
Ted was wearing a shirt that I wanted to say, what were we doing with that shirt?
泰德穿了一件衬衫，我很想说，我们穿那件衬衫到底在干什么？
There was some weird shirts.
有些衬衫真的很诡异。
I called it out, so I was watching it with my wife, and I said, what's going on with that shirt right there?
我把它指出来了，当时我和我妻子一起看，我说：那件衬衫到底是怎么回事？
What's happening, Wyze?
这到底是要闹哪样，威兹（Wyze）？
It's a crate, right?
是个板条箱，对吧？
It had these crazy swirly designs, light colored, but with this red dragon kind of design.
上面有那种疯狂的漩涡图案，颜色很浅，但带着这种红龙一样的设计。
Was it almost, it almost looked like suede or like, kind of cowboy-ish?
是不是有点像，几乎看起来像麂皮，或者有点像牛仔风格？
Cowboy-ish, yes.
牛仔风格，是的。
And also for some reason, and I don't know what, me and the costume designer at the time were deciding, but like, it was either, sometimes I'd wear the shirts open, but I don't understand why I didn't button them more.
而且出于某种原因，我也不知道为什么，当时我和服装设计师在决定，但就像，要么是，有时我会把衬衫敞开穿，但我真不明白为什么我当时不多扣几颗扣子。
There was always, there were always like three or four buttons on it.
总是，上面总是有三四颗扣子。
All of the buttons open.
所有的扣子都敞开着。
All of it like, sometimes too.
有时全都是这样。
Yeah.
是啊。
All of the buttons open, I can make a sale for it still.
扣子全敞开，我到现在还能靠它卖出点什么呢。
Okay, but you only want, when it's some of them, it's weird.
好吧，但你只想，当只是其中几颗的时候，这很奇怪。
Some of them, they were just such a weird thing.
其中一些，它们实在是太奇怪了。
That's all.
就这样。
Yeah.
是啊。
All I will say is this, I will say this, I called out that shirt and my wife watching with me, she goes, I like that shirt.
我只想说这个，我想说的是，我指出了那件衬衫，和我一起看的我妻子说，我喜欢那件衬衫。
And I was gonna go on a whole tirade against the shirt.
而我本来打算对那件衬衫大加挞伐。
And then she was like, I kind of like it's, I don't know, maybe works for something.
然后她说，我其实挺喜欢它的，我不知道，也许在某些方面还挺合适的。
By the way, the internet points out many times that Ted and the color, I'm colorblind, I trust the internet, that the color of Ted and Robin shirts are the same as the color of Ted's parents' shirts.
顺便说一句，互联网多次指出，泰德和颜色——我是色盲，我相信互联网——泰德和罗宾衬衫的颜色和泰德父母衬衫的颜色是一样的。
I thought that was intentional, although I forgot whether it was intentional for me, but from the cost environment.
我以为那是刻意安排的，虽然我忘了对我来说是不是刻意的，但从服装部门的角度来看。
It's hard to say that shirt was like, ah, well, classic, it was just a period, the function of being 2006.
很难说那件衬衫就像是，啊，嗯，经典，那只是一个时代，2006年的产物。
Was that a thing in 2006?
那是2006年的流行趋势吗？
I thought there were a few shirts but I'm like, whatever, I don't know what was happening.
我以为有几件衬衫，但我想，随便吧，我不知道当时发生了什么。
But I don't think it was, it wasn't the brunch shirt.
但我不认为那是，那不是早午餐衬衫。
It was another shirt.
那是另一件衬衫。
It was another one.
是另一件。
It was when they step out in the hall with his dad.
那是他们和他父亲一起走到走廊里的时候。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
And it was, yeah, when you texted me that, I was like, I know exactly what Sherrod Josh is talking about.
而且是，是的，当你给我发那个信息时，我就想，我完全知道乔希说的是哪件衬衫。
But you know what's funny, when they put you in these clothes, you, like sometimes they'll be like, no, no, no, no, it looks great.
但你知道有趣的是什么吗，当他们给你穿这些衣服时，你，就像有时候他们会说，不，不，不，不，这看起来好极了。
You're like, really?
你就会想，真的吗？
But you trust them, you know?
但你信任他们，你知道吗？
And I, you know, I- How often did you veto?
而且我，你知道，我——你行使否决权的频率有多高？
How often did you veto?
你行使否决权的频率有多高？
You can veto.
你可以否决。
but sometimes you'll have like a quick change and they'll be like, oh, this is just like a 30 second pop, right?
但有时你会有快速换装的时候，他们会说，哦，这只是一个30秒的镜头，对吧？
I think I got more as the show went on, I got a little more, I would, I exercised my veto power and more.
我觉得随着剧集的播出，我越来越多了，我变得更多了一点，我会，我更多地行使了我的否决权。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I would say, I don't feel good in this or this, you know, but sometimes you just look back and some of those like cowboy shirts and some of those things, you're like, wow.
我会说，我穿这个或那个感觉不太好，你知道，但有时你回过头来看，其中一些牛仔衬衫和其中的一些东西，你会想，哇。
There was a lot of cowboy shit going on.
当时有很多西部牛仔风的服装。
Maybe was that a thing in 2006?
也许那是2006年的流行趋势？
More than I thought it was?
比我想象的还要流行？
That's the western, yeah.
那是西部风，对。
It was a little Western thing.
有点西部风。
I don't know.
我不知道。
But why Ted, why is Ted wearing that?
但为什么是泰德，为什么泰德要穿那个？
I don't, it was, it was odd in retrospect.
我不知道，现在回想起来，这很奇怪。
And even in the moment, I was like, I don't know.
甚至在当时，我也在想，我不知道。
I think Jason was a little more like, don't put me in stuff that I feel weird in.
我觉得杰森更倾向于：别让我穿让我觉得怪异的衣服。
Like, I think I was a little more like, okay, even, I guess.
就像，我觉得我更倾向于：好吧，甚至，我猜。
But who knows?
但谁知道呢？
Right.
对。
And I'm sure he felt great about the zip away pants for the calves.
而且我敢肯定，他对那条小腿处能拉链拆卸的裤子感觉棒极了。
Well, also.
嗯，还有。
He'd do it for comedy.
他这么做是为了搞笑。
He would do it for God bless me.
他这么做是为了……天啊。
He'd do it for comedic purposes.
他这么做纯粹是为了喜剧效果。
Were there things that you liked Ted in?
泰德穿过的衣服里，有什么是你喜欢的吗？
were there things where you would get in the wardrobe and you go, this is Ted Mosby.
有没有那么一些服装，你一穿上就会觉得：“这就是泰德·莫斯比。”
I feel like this is the look, clearly this wasn't dead, what we're talking about.
我感觉这就是那种造型，显然这并不是指我们刚才说的死去的那些。
A lot of it was, because you're in costume all day, essentially.
很多时候确实是这样，因为你基本上整天都穿着戏服。
And a lot of them on the show.
而且剧里有很多套。
Yeah, but you start actually wanting them more to dress like you, like you.
对，但你后来其实更希望他们穿得像你，就像你本人一样。
Right.
对。
Like I do wear a lot of plaid shirts.
就像我平时穿很多格子衬衫。
I do wear a lot of T-shirts.
我穿很多T恤。
I do wear jeans.
我穿牛仔裤。
I do wear whatever.
我随便穿什么。
I do wear justice khakis, no.
我穿正义卡其裤，才怪。
But I think you start just wanting to be comfortable.
但我觉得你开始只是想要穿得舒服。
Yeah, because it's all day long for hours and hours and hours and you're living on that set.
对，因为一穿就是整整一天，几个小时又几个小时，你就生活在那个片场里。
I have certain like, golds and yellows kind of make my skin look weird.
我有一些比如金色和黄色之类的颜色，会让我的皮肤看起来很怪。
So we always avoided, we mostly avoided those, you know, just things that you kind of know what your palette is, I guess, but mostly you end up, it's almost like you're going shopping.
所以我们总是避免，我们大多会避开那些颜色，你知道的，就是你大概知道自己适合什么色系，不过大部分时候到头来，感觉就像去购物一样。
like you have a wardrobe fitting, right?
就像你要去试装对吧？
And you go in there and they got a huge rack of clothes and you just burn through a lot of clothes and you just yes, no, they just yes, no it real quick.
你走进试衣间，那里有一大排衣服，然后你快速浏览很多衣服，马上就能定下要还是不要，非常快地做出决定。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And then sometimes they, I remember they didn't even, sometimes there'd be like, okay, you're only in one, that you're in the shirt the whole episode.
然后有时他们——我记得甚至有时会这样，比如：“好吧，你这场戏只有一套衣服，这一集里你都穿着这件衬衫。”
So let's find one you really feel comfortable in.
所以让我们找一件你真正觉得舒服的。
Yeah.
对。
You know?
你知道吗？
But largely you would, you would, whatever the yes was, you know, you're like a preschooler, like you go into your dressing room in the morning and it's laid out for you, you know?
但大部分时候，只要选定了，你就会像个学龄前儿童一样，早上走进化妆间，衣服都已经为你摆好了，你知道吧？
It is really weird.
这真的很诡异。
There is this.
确实有这种感觉。
There is an infantilizing quality, right?
有一种将人婴儿化的特质，对吧？
To be good.
好吧。
Okay.
行。
Now wear this.
现在穿这个。
Someone that follows you to go to the bathroom to make sure you come back for you your lunch.
甚至有人跟着你去洗手间，确保你回来吃午饭。
He's almost done.
他快好了。
And there's people on headsets going.
而且还有人用对讲机说。
He's almost done.
他快好了。
I think this is a giant dump.
我觉得这是一次超级大号。
I think so.
我也这么觉得。
We got to give this extra time.
我们得给这个多留点时间。
I'm listening at the door.
我在门听着呢。
It's really weird.
这真的很怪。
It is really strange.
确实很奇怪。
But yeah, the bell tower joke.
不过，说回那个钟楼的笑话。
I did write that down uncle per his perfect vision.
我确实把那个记下来了，叔叔，根据他完美的视力。
Such a dark joke.
真是个细思极恐的笑话。
It was a very dark but very smart joke.
这是一个非常黑暗但非常聪明的笑话。
Yeah, Christine Rose's fake reactions to the dad making out the waitress was really funny.
对，克里斯蒂娜·罗斯对爸爸跟女服务员亲热的假反应真的很好笑。
Don't do that.
别那样。
I liked that they didn't have a bitter divorce.
我喜欢他们没有经历痛苦的离婚。
I liked that.
我喜欢这点。
I thought that was nice to see a couple that was like, they were through whatever the hard part was and they were running for each other.
我觉得看到一对这样的夫妻挺好的，他们已经熬过了最艰难的部分，而且他们是奔向彼此的。
Ted's dad was like, he's a nice guy.
泰德的爸爸就像是在说，他是个好人。
I love that it was Ted's worth a dentist or dentist.
我喜欢泰德的价值是一个牙医还是牙医。
You remember him?
你还记得他吗？
He did your braces.
他给你整过牙。
And I love that it wasn't the cliche they fucking hate each other reveal.
而且我喜欢这并没有落入“他们恨死对方了”的俗套揭晓。
The reveal was they're okay.
揭晓的结果是他们挺好的。
They've processed it and they're okay.
他们已经接受并消化了，他们挺好的。
This was the best thing for both of them.
这对他们俩来说都是最好的事。
They just didn't bother to tell their children because it didn't feel Christmassy.
他们只是懒得告诉孩子们，因为这感觉不太适合圣诞节。
Yeah.
对。
You know, there was an episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm where Larry's mom died and they didn't tell him because they didn't want to bother him.
你知道，《抑制热情》里有一集，拉里的妈妈去世了，他们没告诉他，因为他们不想打扰他。
I only heard about this one recently.
我最近才听说这个。
I missed this one somehow.
我不知怎么漏掉了这一集。
We did this before that, I think.
我想我们在这之前就做过了。
I'm not saying Larry David ripped this off, but yeah.
我不是说拉里·大卫抄袭了这个，但是吧。
No, we definitely, I don't think Larry David to watch the show, but that ending bit, that tag where Ted slowly realizes his grandmother's dad.
不，我们绝对……我不觉得拉里·大卫看了这部剧，但是那个结尾的片段，泰德慢慢意识到他奶奶的爸爸。
It's no longer with us.
已经不在了。
It was, you played that really, that was a great slow burn.
那是……你演得真的很好，那是一个非常棒的渐进式包袱。
That was probably the biggest lap.
那可能全场笑得最大声的地方。
Watching him, it's my wife, Rebecca was, that was her biggest laugh.
看着他，我妻子丽贝卡，那是她笑得最大声的地方。
And another, by the way, I said, I think there's another dark family-related death joke, and this is it.
还有另外一个，顺便说一句，我说过，我觉得还有一个关于家庭死亡的黑暗笑话，就是这个。
This is another Stephen Lloyd joke of the day grandma.
这是史蒂芬·劳埃德的又一个关于奶奶的笑话。
That's a very, that's a very similar joke.
那是一个非常、非常相似的笑话。
I said that with love and respect.
我是带着爱和敬意说这话的。
Stephen Lloyd couldn't have too many dead grandparents.
史蒂芬·劳埃德的剧里死去的祖父母可不能太多。
That was just, there's a body count in a Stephen Lloyd episode.
那简直是……史蒂芬·劳埃德的一集里可是有死亡人数统计的。
Yeah.
对。
It's like Quentin Tarantino.
就像昆汀·塔伦蒂诺一样。
I liked when Barney said, oh, he mentioned he was divorced us in a totally space.
我喜欢巴尼说，哦，他在一个完全不相关的空间里提到他离婚了。
Yes, I love that throw again, very well thrown away.
对，我喜欢那种漫不经心的小包袱，抛得太好了。
So much of the best comedy is thrown away.
很多最好的喜剧都是漫不经心抛出来的。
We were saying that about Michael Gross.
我们之前聊迈克尔·格罗斯时也这么说过。
That's how he was on family ties.
他在《家庭纽带》里就是这样的。
He was, he played this like that.
他当时就是这么演的。
and that's a great throwaway joke.
那真是一个极好的随性笑话。
That's if there's one lesson here today, just throw the jokes away.
如果今天能学到一个教训的话，那就是随性地把笑话抛出来就行。
Don't hit him too hard.
别太用力。
Even Ted going, sure.
甚至连泰德说“当然”。
Like your little throwaway, sure, was my favorite joke in the last time.
就像你随口说的那句“当然”，是我上次最喜欢的笑话。
I kind of think of those jokes a little bit, like a moth lance on your shoulder and you just go.
我有点把那些笑话想象成，就像一只蛾子落在你的肩膀上，然后你只是……
Yeah, don't freak out.
对，别大惊小怪的。
You just flick it away, you know?
你只是把它弹开，对吧？
You just, it's just a little kick.
你只是，就轻轻掸一下。
It just doesn't take me.
它不会影响我。
That'll get it done.
这样就搞定了。
I did find myself the scene outside with the four of them, Ted's parents and Robin and Ted.
我确实觉得外面那场戏很有意思，他们四个在一起，泰德的父母、罗宾和泰德。
I thought it was so moving that just, when I have kids and I tell them the story of how I met their mother, I'm gonna tell them the whole damn story.
我觉得那真的很感人，就是，当我以后有了孩子，我要把我是怎么遇到他们母亲的故事讲给他们听时，我要把整个该死的故事都讲给他们听。
Yeah.
对啊。
He commits to, he's like, I don't like these, I don't like these half details.
他下定决心，他心想，我不喜欢这些，我不喜欢这种语焉不详的细节。
I want to know these people more, I want to know where I came from, I want to know my history.
我想更多地了解这些人，我想知道我来自哪里，我想了解我的历史。
And in some ways, he over-corrects, like he tells them too much, it could be argued.
在某种程度上，他矫枉过正了，比如说他告诉了他们太多，这可以说是肯定的。
But there's something, I think every generation is trying to remedy something that they felt like they didn't get.
但有些东西，我觉得每一代人都在试图弥补某种他们觉得自己没有得到的东西。
I want to explain myself to my kids because my parents didn't explain themselves to me.
我想向我的孩子们解释我自己，因为我的父母没有向我解释过他们自己。
Yeah, what was it?
对啊，那是怎么回事？
Oh, it's a great story.
哦，那是个很棒的故事。
We met at a bar.
我们在酒吧相遇。
Yeah, and this fellow visits an Irish bar, which is another Ted Robin parallel of how they met.
对，然后这家伙去了一家爱尔兰酒吧，这也是泰德和罗宾相遇方式的又一个平行呼应。
There's so many smart meta kind of in jokes in this thing, Craig.
这里面有那么多聪明的元梗、藏梗，克雷格。
It's really is later.
确实是这样，而且更深层。
I know the internet folks tend to get a little conspiratorial, but they're like that because there is so much woven and it's densely packed with stuff.
我知道互联网上的朋友们往往有点阴谋论倾向，但他们之所以这样，是因为里面编织的东西实在是太多了，而且内容极其密集。
It's Barney entering and thinking he's getting applause from what is clearly a wall if we're to believe the reality of the apartment.
比如巴尼走进来，以为自己赢得了一面墙的掌声，如果我们相信这间公寓的现实设定的。
And then Ted is saying, I'm going to tell this show.
然后泰德说，我要讲述这个节目。
This show you're seeing, I'm going to tell it.
你现在看到的这个节目，我要把它讲出来。
It's 2006.
现在是2006年。
Now I'm going to tell my kids in 2030 what's happening as we're all watching this story.
现在我要在2030年把正在发生的事情讲给我的孩子们听，就好像我们所有人都在看着这个故事一样。
That is, I loved it.
那真是，我太喜欢了。
That was my favorite moment of the whole episode, because that was the show explaining itself as a show, which is a story to kids and parents all want their kids to understand them.
那是整集里我最喜欢的时刻，因为那是剧集在以剧集本身的形式进行自我诠释，这是一个讲给孩子听的故事，而父母都希望他们的孩子能理解他们。
And there's just something, there's a lot of layers there.
而且这里面有某种，有很多层次的东西。
And I think it's very human.
而且我认为这非常人性化。
We all tell stories.
我们都在讲故事。
We all need to make sense of it in a story.
我们都需要在故事中把这一切理出头绪。
And then you think, why is he taking this much time to tell in such granular detail this story?
然后你会想，他为什么花这么长时间，用如此细致的细节来讲述这个故事？
And it's like, well, because he has this wound.
这就好像是，嗯，因为他有这样一个心结。
He didn't get it.
他没有得到。
He didn't get the story.
他没有得到那个故事。
He wants the story.
他想要那个故事。
So so he has to create it for himself.
所以，所以他必须为自己创造一个。
He's being the parent and he didn't have.
他正在扮演他曾经没有的那个父母。
We see them make a little progress in this episode.
我们看到他们在这一集中取得了一点进展。
Ted learns about his parents in a way he didn't know before, but it's only a little progress.
泰德以一种他以前不知道的方式了解了他的父母，但这只是一小步进展。
You don't know if it might revert the next week.
你不知道下周它会不会又倒退回去。
In fact, the tag reverts them back to, I'm gonna get some juice instead of telling you your grandmother died.
事实上，片尾彩蛋又把他们打回了原形，变成“我去买点果汁”而不是“我要告诉你你奶奶去世了”。
But Ted calls his shot like Babe Ruth, I'm gonna tell this story one day and by God he does it.
但泰德像贝比·鲁斯一样，提前放话了，我总有一天要讲这个故事，天呐，他真的做到了。
And here we are.
然后我们就在这里了。
You know how I make your mother always, even in, like this is a big capital C comedy episode.
你知道我是怎么让你们的母亲……总是这样，哪怕是在，比如这算是一集大写C的喜剧。
Like this is a funny episode, a lot of actions, broken plates, like it's farce.
就像这是一集很搞笑的剧，有很多动作戏、碎盘子，简直就像闹剧一样。
But I think in almost every episode, you could probably map this.
但我认为几乎在每一集里，你都可以找出这样的轨迹。
There's always a moment that's just a little more wistful.
总有一个时刻会显得稍微有那么一点惆怅。
Or a little more of like an exhale, you know?
或者稍微有一点像松了一口气的感觉，你知道吗？
And that for me, this moment was that in this episode.
对我来说，这一集的那个时刻就是这样。
Yeah, we did not feel like we were great farce writers or great, like here's one big long 12 minute funny scene.
是的，我们并不觉得自己是什么伟大的闹剧编剧，或者觉得“看，这里有一个长达12分钟的好笑场景”。
It's going to be slamming doors.
那将是一场伴随着摔门声的闹剧。
This is our version of that.
这就是我们对那种风格的诠释。
Our version of slamming doors and breaking plates is we will jump around back and forth to the beginning and the end of the story three times and chop it up, but this is our farce.
我们拍滑稽剧的方式——也就是那种重重关上门、砸碎盘子的桥段——就是把故事的开头和结尾来来回回跳切三次，剪得支离破碎，这就是我们的滑稽闹剧。
This is the way we, on how much mother, tell the farce episode and tell the slamming doors episode.
这就是我们这些“老爸老妈”剧组的人，拍摄滑稽剧和关门戏的方式。
And I loved that about it because it has that energy of a zany farce episode, but it is a very pulp fiction along the way.
我特别喜欢这一点，因为它有一种疯狂滑稽剧的能量，但一路走来又非常具有低俗小说（Pulp Fiction）的风格。
And I think I really liked that.
我觉得我真的很喜欢这样。
I think early in season two, we thought, we have to come out with some really big comedy episodes.
我想在第二季刚开始时，我们就觉得，我们必须推出一些非常盛大的喜剧剧集。
We need energy, we need to grab an audience, but I don't think we sacrificed in this one, at least what made the show rhythmically interesting and eccentric, and I like that.
我们需要活力，我们需要吸引观众，但我觉得我们在这集里并没有做出牺牲——至少没有牺牲这部剧在节奏上的趣味和古怪，我挺喜欢这一点的。
So this is a fun one to rewatch.
所以重温这一集很有意思。
No, it was a, it's a really fun one.
不，这集真的很搞笑、很有意思。
I like this episode.
我很喜欢这一集。
Stephen Lloyd, props, well done, well written.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德（Stephen Lloyd），道具组，干得漂亮，写得真好。
And yeah, this one holds up.
而且，这一集经得起时间考验。
A lot of the others, I don't know.
至于其他很多集，我就不知道了。
I don't know.
我真不知道。
We have been informed by our wonderful producer, Alec Lev, that we got a great question in this week that we'd like to spend a couple minutes answering.
我们伟大的制片人亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）通知我们，本周我们收到了一个非常棒的问题，我们想花几分钟时间来回答它。
But also, if you want to write a question to us, if you want to share a tale or a story or anything about what How I Met Your Mother means to you when you discovered the show, how many times you watched it, why you keep watching it over and over and over again, please go to howwemadeyourmother.com, Quimium.com, go to contact and should be pretty self-explanatory, but we'd love to hear from you, whether it's an audio note or a written note.
不过另外，如果你想给我们写信提问，如果你想分享一个故事、一段经历，或者任何关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么、你是什么时候发现这部剧的、你看了多少遍、为什么你一遍又一遍地反复观看它的感受，请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 或 Quimium.com，点击“联系我们”（contact），页面说明应该很清楚了。不管是用语音留言还是文字留言，我们都非常期待听到你的声音。
And Alec, what was this question?
亚历克，这个问题是什么？
This is from our very good friend to the show, Swarly Memes, again, for the win with their question.
这个问题来自我们节目的忠实老朋友“Swarly Memes”，他们再次凭这个问题胜出了。
Swarly says, in this episode, Ted finds out that his parents divorced after realizing how different they were.
Swarly 问，在这一集中，泰德发现他的父母在意识到彼此有多大不同后离婚了。
One of those differences being that his dad always wanted kids while his his mom never did.
其中一个不同点是，他爸爸一直想要孩子，而他妈妈从来不想要。
Ironically, Ted is about to have to make a similar choice with Robin, who also doesn't want children.
具有讽刺意味的是，泰德即将和同样不想要孩子的罗宾面临类似的抉择。
Even though Ted didn't really know this about his parents, he still seems to be repeating the same pattern.
尽管泰德之前并不真正了解父母的这段经历，但他似乎仍在重复同样的模式。
Do you think that we sometimes carry these kinds of generational patterns with us, almost like unconscious curses that can pass down whether through family dynamics or even something deeper like our DNA?
你认为我们有时会把这种代际模式带在身边吗？就像无意识的诅咒一样，通过家族动态甚至更深层的DNA代代相传？
Damn, Swarly memes.
天哪，Swarly memes。
It's a smart question.
这是一个很聪明的问题。
It's a disturbing and smart question.
这是一个让人不安又聪明的问题。
And in some ways, I'm like, I don't know if we are credentialed to answer that.
在某些方面，我觉得，我不知道我们是否有资格回答这个问题。
Like I think it's a- Can you get your data?
就像我觉得这是一个——你能把你的资料拿来吗？
It's a somewhat, I mean, it's definitely a psychological question, but it's somewhat metaphysical too.
这在某种程度上——我的意思是，这绝对是一个心理学问题，但在某种程度上也是形而上学的。
I mean, it reminded me, there's a quote, a man often meets his destiny on the road he took to avoid it.
我是说，这让我想起了一句名言：一个人往往在为了逃避命运而选择的道路上与命运相遇。
Right.
没错。
You know, there's something about like, Ted is trying to not be these people.
你知道，这有点像是，泰德正极力避免成为那样的人。
right.
没错。
But he almost is he's magnetized to this woman that actually is does rhyme with his parents, even up to meeting in an Irish bar.
但他几乎是被磁铁一样吸引向了这个女人，她实际上——确实和他的父母有相似之处，甚至连在爱尔兰酒吧相遇都如出一辙。
Yeah.
对啊。
You know, there there's something it's um, you know, Harville Hendricks's work on I think it's Harville Hendricks on the Amago, which is like the Amago is how you learn love in your family of origin.
你知道，这其中有些东西，呃，你知道的，哈维尔·亨德里克斯（Harville Hendricks）关于——我想是哈维尔·亨德里克斯关于“意象匹配”（Imago）的研究，也就是说，“意象”是你如何在原生家庭中学习爱的。
And we're often we often are magnetized to people that Mirror back or or have some overlap with that kind of love we experienced in our with our primary caregivers Yeah, but the hope is that Your marriage becomes a place where you quote unquote like complete your childhood Where where the your partner does a couple things a little bit better than your primary caregivers did But still has some of the same resonances or frequencies so you can you can And revisit and actually grow through, you know, with another conscious adult.
我们经常像被磁铁吸引一样，去寻找那些能映射出或与我们在主要抚养人那里体验到的那种爱有所重合的人。是的，但理想情况下，你的婚姻会成为这样一个地方：你在其中“完成”了你的童年，你的伴侣在某些方面比你的主要抚养人做得稍微好一点，但仍然保留着某些相同的共鸣或频率，这样你就可以和一个成熟的有意识的成年人一起重新审视并真正获得成长。
But that's why relationships, you know, start off in this swirl of chemistry and intensity and connection.
但这就是为什么人际关系总是始于化学反应、强烈激情和深刻连结的旋涡。
And then you, there's a lot of pain that gets provoked in a good relationship, you know, because you're going to hit some of these landmines.
然后你会发现，在一段好的关系中会激发出许多痛苦，你知道的，因为你们会触雷。
But that's your trigger, you're like, oh, okay, if you know enough, you're conscious enough, you've learned enough about this stuff.
但那是你的触发点，你会想，哦，好吧，如果你了解得足够多，有足够的意识，对这些事情有了足够的了解。
You realize, oh, that's where the real work of relationship.
你会意识到，哦，这才是人际关系真正的功课所在。
That's where the intimacy develops when you say, like, oh, I'm really hurting right now or that.
当你开口说“哦，我现在真的很受伤”或者诸如此类的话时，亲密感就是这样建立起来的。
That's where you got to be comfortable at talking through things.
这就是你必须放轻松与人沟通的地方。
Otherwise, you'll act out in all sorts of strange ways.
否则，你会以各种奇怪的方式表现出抗拒或失常。
Yeah.
没错。
And that resonates forward to when you have kids of your own too, and you're going, what patterns am I trying to break?
而这种影响也会延续到你以后有了自己的孩子身上，你会想：我究竟在试图打破哪些模式？
What works?
什么方法管用？
What did I like that my parents did?
我喜欢我父母做的哪些事？
What parent?
父母……
What am I definitely not going to do?
我绝对不要做什么？
And then sometimes you catch yourself doing shit you didn't want to do.
然后有时你会发现自己正在做出那些你曾发誓绝不做出的破事。
And you're in the middle of second.
而你现在正处于第二阶段。
I can't believe I'm being this cliche right now.
我真不敢相信自己现在会这么老套。
I mean, this was the thing I didn't want to do.
我是说，这是我以前最不想做的事。
And it's just, it's like a tug of war.
这感觉就像是在拔河。
It really is like this very delicate dance because of course there are things you want to emulate.
这确实像是一支非常微妙的舞蹈，因为当然有些东西你想去效仿。
And of course, there are things you want to dodge.
当然，也有些东西你想极力避开。
And some of it, the DNA part of Squarly means question is really interesting because you're like, can you dodge the fate of your own DNA?
其中一部分，关于Squarly的DNA的那种提问真的很有趣，因为你会想：你能逃避自身DNA的命运吗？
Can you change yourself on that kind of molecular level?
你能在那样的分子层面上改变自己吗？
I like to believe you can, but maybe it's really, really hard.
我愿意相信你可以，但也许这真的、真的很难。
It takes a lot of really conscious work.
这需要付出大量真正有意识的努力。
I mean, some of it is just like even dumb stuff.
我的意思是，有些时候甚至只是些蠢事。
Like my friend, Michael, told me that when he was a kid, him and his brothers, the thing about their father that drove them crazy was he could not sit down on the couch or get out of the couch without going like grunting, like everything.
比如我的朋友迈克尔告诉我，他小时候，他和他的兄弟们对他们父亲最抓狂的一点是，他每次坐上沙发或从沙发上站起来时都会发出哼哧哼哧的声音，就好像什么都……
It was like, they were like, you don't have to make a sound.
就好像，他们会说，你根本不用发出声音。
He said literally the day he turned 40.
他说就在他满40岁的那天。
He suddenly, I've also like, my sneeze, this is my dad's not as allergic as me.
他突然……我也有同感，比如我的喷嚏，我爸没我那么过敏。
My sneezes have gotten so fucking middle-aged, like thunderous, and I'm like, what is going, like, why can't I sneeze with some, like, modest sneezes?
我的喷嚏声变得真他妈的中年化，就像打雷一样，我就想，这是怎么回事，为什么我打喷嚏就不能稍微……文雅一点？
Like that, a part of my shit.
就像那样，真是一团糟。
Is that good?
这好吗？
Can there be a liberation in that?
其中会不会有一种解脱感？
I'm just gonna, I mean, look, it feels great.
我只是想说……我是说，听着，感觉太棒了。
I'm not gonna lie, I'm having a great time over here.
我不想撒谎，我在这里过得非常开心。
I've never felt more alive in those sneezes.
我从来没有在那些喷嚏中感到如此充满生机。
That's what I'm saying though.
不过这就是我想说的。
Maybe there's a certain, there's a certain fuck it too.
也许这里面也带有一种“管他呢”的态度。
And you're not really harming anyone with those sneezes.
而且你打那些喷嚏并没有真正伤害到任何人。
I guess maybe Jordana could disagree.
我想乔安娜可能不这么认为。
But do you have moments, Craig, where you feel like, oh, my dad has taken over my body.
但是克雷格，你有没有那么一刻觉得，哦，我爸接管了我的身体。
Like I feel, yeah.
就好像我感觉，是的。
Or you catch yourself in a light or a picture and you're like, oh, there he is.
或者你在某道光线或某张照片里看到自己，然后你会想，哦，他就在那儿。
I would see my dad biting his nails and his like 40s and 50s and then be like, I'm not gonna be biting my fucking nails.
我以前看到我爸在四五十岁的时候咬指甲，然后就会想：我才不要去他妈的咬指甲。
And I'm like 50 years old.
结果等我到了50岁。
Cut to me like watching our show for this podcast.
镜头切换到我看着我们这个播客的节目。
I was like, rah, rah, rah, rah, rah, rah, rah, rah.
我当时就……（模仿怪叫声）。
I was like, what the fuck are you doing?
我当时想：你他妈的在干什么？
It's like, and it's like, shit, I'm still doing that.
这就好像是，妈的，我居然还在这样做。
Yeah, yeah, I catch myself and old guy stuff.
对，对，我经常会发现自己身上有老头子的做派。
Oh, definitely old guy stuff, sounds, sensations.
哦，绝对是老头子的做派、声音和感觉。
It strikes me that in some way is the work of forgiving your parents becomes more urgent the older you get, because there's so much inside of you and there's such a ticking time, but I'm about to go off of them in you that if you don't forgive them, it can turn into self-loathing.
我突然发现，在某种程度上，随着年龄的增长，原谅父母这件事变得更加紧迫，因为你内心深处有那么多东西，就像一个滴答作响的时钟，关于他们的一切即将融入你的身体，如果你不原谅他们，这可能会变成一种对自己的厌恶。
You know, you can turn into like, oh, I don't like this.
你知道的，你可能会变成那种“哦，我不喜欢这样”的状态。
But otherwise, you know, or you can go, they're wonderful.
但换个角度，你知道的，或者你可以说，他们很棒。
They're, you know, they're in me and it's good.
他们，你知道的，他们就在我体内，这很好。
It's okay.
没关系。
And they're right.
而且他们是对的。
Rebecca wishes she could apologize to her mom because Rebecca would, her ex mom would sort of forget a word at the end of a sentence, just take a little pause to get there and now Rebecca is doing that.
丽贝卡希望她能向她妈妈道歉，因为丽贝卡会——她的前妈妈在句尾时会记不起某个词，稍微停顿一下才能想起来，而现在丽贝卡也开始这样了。
And Rebecca would always be the corrector when she was a teenager mom.
丽贝卡在当青少年的妈妈时，总是扮演那个纠正错误的人。
This is the word you're saying.
“你要说的是这个词。”
You know, our daughter Celia who's nine and sometimes jumps in and does that to Rebecca.
你知道的，我们的女儿西莉亚九岁了，有时会突然插嘴对丽贝卡做这种事。
And Rebecca said to me one night, she's like, I wish my mom were still alive.
有一天晚上丽贝卡对我说，她说：“我真希望我妈妈还在世。”
so I could apologize because now that it's happening to me, it feels so shitty.
“这样我就可以向她道歉了，因为现在这落到我头上，感觉太糟糕了。”
And you're like, just give me another second.
而你就会觉得：再给我一秒钟。
I'm gonna get to this word.
我一定会说到这个词的。
I swear to God, I'm gonna get there.
我发誓，我一定会说到的。
Yeah, it's the circle game.
对，这就是那个转圈游戏。
Aging is tricky.
变老是很微妙的。
I mean, we have to have compassion for ourselves and others as we go through it.
我是说，我们在经历这一切时，必须对自己和他人多一些同理心。
It's just, it's just, yeah, yeah.
这只是，这只是，对，对。
It's a missing piece.
这是一个缺失的部分。
And I think that the thing of trying to dodge it or make it look some other way than it is, I think the acceptance piece of it and ourselves and others is like a really kind of a missing piece of like 21st century social media life that we're all living.
而且我认为，那种试图逃避它，或者把它伪装成另一种样子的做法，我觉得接受它本身、接受自己和他人，就像是我们所有人都在经历的21世纪社交媒体生活中一种真正缺失的东西。
We're all gonna get old.
我们都会变老。
We're all gonna find those things.
我们都会经历那些事情。
We're all gonna experience those humbling things.
我们都会经历那些让人感到卑微的时刻。
It just happens.
它就是会发生。
Have you ever come across oldster magazine on Substack?
你有没有在 Substack 上看过 Oldster 杂志？
No, no.
没有，没有。
It's Sari Bottom.
好像叫萨里·博顿。
I think her name is who runs it.
我想经营它的人叫这个名字。
And there's like an oldster questionnaire.
上面有一个老者问卷。
And it's really just for people.
这真的是给人们准备的。
I mean, she's interviewed people from their 20s all the way up to their 90s.
我是说，她采访过从20多岁到90多岁的人。
But it's a questionnaire about like, what's been the most delightful thing about aging?
但这其实是一份关于这些问题的问卷：变老最让人愉快的事情是什么？
What has surprised you the most?
什么最让你感到惊讶？
What's been the biggest bummer?
最让人沮丧的事情是什么？
Like, who you thought you'd be when you were a kid or are you vastly different?
比如，你小时候以为自己会成为什么样的人，或者你现在的变化很大吗？
Like they're really probing beautiful, interesting questions that I find myself turning to it quite a bit whenever it pops up.
这些都是非常深入、美丽且有趣的问题，每当它弹出来时，我发现自己总会忍不住去看看。
Like I'm really- I'm gonna look at that.
比如我真的很——我得去看看。
Yeah, Oldster magazine, it's called.
对，就叫 Oldster 杂志。
That's great.
那太棒了。
And I would say, let those sneezes fly, man.
我想说，伙计，让那些喷嚏尽情打出来吧。
Except those gigantic sneezes just fucking do it because the giving less bucks part as the best part of it.
除了那些巨大的喷嚏，他妈的尽管打吧，因为不再在乎别人的看法才是最棒的部分。
I'm gonna wake Jordana up with a startle and I'm gonna go Craig told me I'm allowed to do this.
我要把乔丹娜惊醒，然后对她说，克雷格告诉我我可以这么做。
Craig says it's okay, Jordana's gonna yell at me.
克雷格说没关系，乔丹娜肯定会对我吼。
All right, we have a letter to Alec.
好了，我们有一封写给亚历克的信。
We do, we have a great letter.
没错，我们有一封很棒的信。
All right, hello Josh, Craig and Alec.
好的，你好，乔希、克雷格和亚历克。
Alec, they don't know we shot you out, so I'm glad.
亚历克，他们不知道我们把你喊出来了，我很高兴。
And spelled correctly with the K.
而且拼写很对，是用 K 的。
Oh, this is a real one right here.
哦，这可真是个正主。
You've made it, you've arrived.
你成功了，你出息了。
My name is Jonathan and this show means so much to me that I can't put it into words.
我叫乔纳森，这个节目对我意义重大，简直无法用言语表达。
I was first introduced to Hymmium back in 2010.
我最早是在2010年接触到《老爸老妈浪漫史》的。
My family and I had moved back to Mexico from the US.
我和家人从美国搬回了墨西哥。
I was 12 years old, starting junior high.
我当时12岁，刚上初中。
I was 12 years old, starting junior high, and adjusting to school in a different country.
我当时12岁，刚上初中，正在适应一个不同国家的学校生活。
It was during English class when the professor who had also grown up in the US put on the first episode of his favorite show called How I Met Your Mother.
那是英语课上，那位同样在美国长大的老师播放了他最喜欢的节目的第一集，名字叫《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
Oh wow.
哦，哇。
I immediately was hooked.
我立刻就被迷住了。
And the more I watched, the more my love grew for the sitcom.
我看得越多，对这部情景喜剧的喜爱就越深。
Fast forward to 15 years and the show is still very much relatable, probably even more now than it was before.
快进到15年后，这部剧依然非常引人共鸣，可能比以前更有共鸣了。
I see myself relating a lot to Ted, mostly now that I'm the same age as he was when the show first started, wanting to get married and desperately trying to find the so-called one, which frankly seems like an impossible task these days.
我发现自己和特德有很多相似之处，尤其是现在我和他刚开始时一样大，渴望结婚，拼命想找到所谓的“真爱”，坦白说，这些日子这似乎是一个不可能完成的任务。
I also relate a lot to Robin, having gotten my bachelor's degree in journalism a couple years ago and still trying to find a way of getting my career started.
我也觉得我和罗宾很像，几年前我获得了新闻学学士学位，现在仍在努力寻找开启职业生涯的方法。
but unfortunately, with not much luck on my side.
但遗憾的是，我的运气不太好。
With every episode, whether it made me laugh, to forget just a little bit of what was going on in life, or whether it made me sad and showed me that others are going through the same struggles as I do, it provided me with hope that one day, maybe just one day, things will turn out better.
伴随着每一集，无论是让我开怀大笑、暂时忘却生活中的烦恼，还是让我难过并向我展示其他人也在经历与我一样的挣扎，它都给我带来了希望：总有一天，也许就有一天，情况会变得更好。
The hope that I get from watching the show is also the hope I get from listening to this podcast, from how Josh, after doing many pilots with shows that didn't get picked up or got canceled later on, was finally able to be on a show that not only got picked up, it also became one of the best sitcoms of all time.
从看这部节目中获得的希望，也是我听这个播客时获得的希望。正如乔希在演了许多没有被选中或后来被取消的试播集后，终于能够出演一部不仅被选中、还成为史上最佳情景喜剧之一的节目。
From how everything aligned for Craig and Carter and that Starbucks in order to bring this show to life and keep it going for nine seasons.
正如克雷格和卡特在星巴克里的一切契合，才让这部剧得以诞生并延续了九季。
And so many countless stories like Courtney's, Coby's, Ashley's, and many others that are shared on the podcast that let me know that God's timing is perfect and one day I'll get my big break.
还有无数像考特尼、科比、阿什莉以及许多在播客中分享的其他人的故事，让我知道上帝的安排是完美的，总有一天我会迎来我的转机。
With that said, I just wanna say thank you.
话虽如此，我只想说谢谢。
Thank you for creating something that truly became the comfort show I needed at any point in my life and shows me no matter what I may be going through, there's always a reason for me to keep going.
谢谢你们创造了这样一部作品，它真正成为了我生活在任何阶段都需要的情感慰藉，并告诉我，无论我正在经历什么，我总有继续前行的理由。
You guys are the best.
你们是最棒的。
Thanks again.
再次感谢。
Your friend from Utah, Jonathan.
来自犹他州的朋友，乔纳森。
That's lovely.
太可爱了。
There's a twist ending.
还有一个反转结尾。
He was in Utah.
他在犹他州。
Yeah, it was.
对，是这样的。
We moved that out of journey, that story.
我们把这段经历从旅程中移除了。
Yeah.
对。
You know, I love that your teacher showed you the pilot.
你知道的，我很喜欢你的老师给你们看试播集。
It's mind-blowing.
这太不可思议了。
I wonder what, I wonder in what context, but I remember I had this English teacher, my freshman year of high school named Mrs. LaMuth, and I had her also my senior year of creative writing.
我想知道，在什么背景下，但我记得我上高一的时候有位英语老师叫拉穆斯太太，高三上创意写作课时也是她教我。
Great teacher, she passed away a couple years ago.
一位伟大的老师，她几年前去世了。
And before she died, she dropped off all my creative writing that I did for her as a senior, she had saved it.
在她去世前，她把我高三时为她写的所有创意写作作业都留了下来，她一直保存着。
Wow.
哦，哇。
She just left it for as an envelope on our, my mom said Mrs. LaMuth dropped this.
她只是把它们作为一个信封留在我们家，我妈妈说拉穆斯太太送来了这个。
So I got to see all this writing I had done as a senior in high school.
所以我得以看到我高中最后一年写的所有这些文章。
But I remember one day she brought a turntable in, and she played Carol King's tapestry, the song tapestry.
但我记得有一天她带了一个唱盘进来，放了卡罗尔·金的《挂毯》，那首叫《挂毯》的歌。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
And she gave us the lyrics and we analyzed it like poetry.
她把歌词发给我们，我们像分析诗歌一样分析它。
She just wanted us to take it through.
她只是想让我们仔细品味。
And from that moment on, like I've been a huge Carol King fan, that album isn't masterful.
从那一刻起，我就成了卡罗尔·金的超级粉丝，那张专辑简直是大师级的作品。
I'm a masterwork, yeah.
是一部杰作，对。
But that song in particular is so lyrically dense and rich and so beautiful.
但尤其是那首歌，歌词意境深厚、丰富又极其美丽。
And it really, now that I write songs, I even have a deeper appreciation for it, but it really taught me how songs could be poetry and artful.
现在我自己也写歌了，我对它有了更深的欣赏，但它确实教会了我歌曲如何可以像诗歌一样充满艺术感。
It was such a great lesson, but I'm just struck by the power that teachers have to introduce students to art and things they love.
那是一堂非常棒的课，但我深深地感受到老师们引导学生接触艺术和他们所爱之物的巨大力量。
It can affect them for the rest of their lives.
这会影响他们的一生。
Yeah, it's phenomenal.
对，这太了不起了。
It's such an honor when we hear how much mother in a classroom is just so mind-blowing and so cool.
当我们听到有人在课堂上提到《老妈》时，真的是让人脑洞大开又酷毙了。
Thank you, Jonathan, for that story.
谢谢你，乔纳森，分享这个故事。
It's really cool.
真的很酷。
Also, it might not look like it in the moment, but things might be organizing themselves on your behalf.
还有，当时可能看起来不像，但事情可能正在为你默默安排。
I think I've mentioned this.
我想我提到过这个。
I think it's either Larry McMurtry or Cormac McCarthy line.
我觉得这是麦卡锡或科马克·麦卡锡的名言。
You never know what worst luck you're bad luck is saving you from.
你永远不知道最糟糕的运气正在帮你免受怎样的厄运。
Yeah, that's a great line.
是的，这是一句名言。
You know it looks like it looks like things are you know but it's all coalescing and it's I think I think how our mother says look it's a it's a friendly universe it's on your side and just trust.
你知道的，看起来事情好像是这样，但它们都在汇聚，而且我认为，正如《老妈》所说，看吧，这是一个友善的宇宙，它站在你这边，去相信它就行了。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请装备我，在纽约市，所有罪孽都已被原谅。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和分发。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利担任执行制片人。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我、亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue 工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是 Gen Z 大师，是艾米丽·布隆伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple Podcasts 或你常用的播客应用上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》（New York City），由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）创作，配乐由克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）共同完成。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别鸣谢罗拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
欢迎在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的通讯，并访问 JoshRadner.com 了解他的音乐以及更多内容。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说现已在各大书店发售，你也可以访问 CraigThomasWriter.com 查看他的其他发表作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Fathers Society）。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何为本节目旨在筹集资金的先天性小儿心脏病研究持续活动贡献力量，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞的。
Real question, it just hit me, or just no York City.
有个真正的问题突然闪过脑海，或者说，只是没有纽约市。
Derry, here is the, here is the promise at the very beginning of this, if you remember back to the beginning of this podcast, okay, here are some clips, exclusive to you, the how we made your mother fans and the how I met your mother fans, never before heard audio book clips from my debut novel, that's somehow an app and of Josh Radner and Kobe smolders as two of the four characters of the book and here's a little taste of what they do in the audiobook.
黛里，这就是最初的承诺，如果你还记得这个播客刚开始的时候，好吧，这里有一些独家剪辑，专属于你们——《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们。这是我处女作有声书里从未公开过的音频片段，书名有点像个应用，由乔什·拉德纳和科比·史姆德斯饰演书中的四个角色中的两个，以下是他们在有声书中的精彩片段。
The book comes out of this podcast episode is dropping the week of my publication date of the book which is November 4th Tuesday and I'm very very excited for the book and the audiobook also.
这本书的发布与本期播客节目的上线正值同一周，即11月4日周二，我对这本书以及有声书都感到非常非常兴奋。
You should know that you're gonna hear Josh and Kobe reading in character as two of the four characters in this book so you'll hear Kobe introduce herself as the character of Paige, who is married to the character of Rob, who was voiced by Josh Radner, please enjoy.
你们应该知道，接下来会听到乔什和科比以剧中角色的身份进行朗读，他们是书中四个角色中的两个。你会听到科比自我介绍为佩姬（Paige）这个角色，她嫁给了罗布（Rob），罗布由乔什·拉德纳配音，请好好欣赏。
Paige, Rob was now officially off on script.
佩姬，罗布现在正式脱离剧本开始创作了。
And I was just off.
而我则完全脱节了。
Sorry, when I get stressed, I start speaking like the narration on Sex and the City.
抱歉，当我感到压力大时，说话就会变得像《欲望都市》里的旁白一样。
And so began the surreal, unholy process of my husband adapting my book, my life, into a screenplay.
于是，我那超现实的、荒谬的过程开始了——我丈夫把我的书、我的人生改编成剧本。
would grab a coffee and say, have a good day, then walk down the hall to his office and close the door.
他会喝杯咖啡说声“祝你有美好的一天”，然后穿过走廊走进他的办公室，关上门。
I swear I could hear the sound of knives being sharpened in there.
我发誓我能听到里面磨刀的声音。
What was happening to my poor little book behind that door?
我那可怜的小书在那扇门后究竟遭遇了什么？
What was being scrapped?
有什么内容被删掉了？
At lunch, I'd see Rob in the kitchen and expect him to say something about how it was going.
午饭时，我会在厨房见到罗布，本以为他会说点进展如何之类的话。
Nope.
并没有。
He has a thing about not discussing works in progress, which is fine when it's not my book.
他有个原则，那就是不讨论尚未完成的作品——当这不是我的书时，这倒无所谓。
It's like a surgeon stepping out of the OR and not telling you if your loved one survived the surgery.
这就像一个外科医生走出手术室，却不告诉你你的亲人是否挺过了手术。
After lunch, Rob would head back into his office four hours, afraid to stop lest he lose the role he was on.
午饭后，罗布会回到他的办公室一待就是几个小时，生怕停下来就会打断他正好的灵感状态。
I swear, the man did not get up to P when he wrote.
我发誓，这男人写作时连起身上个厕所都没有。
I often wondered if he kept a creepy mason jar under his desk, but I was too scared to check.
我经常纳闷他是不是在桌子底下藏了个瘆人的梅森罐，但我又太害怕而不敢去检查。
To be fair, if some other screenwriter, a stranger, had been hired instead of Rob, I I would've long since been cut out of the process entirely.
平心而论，如果换作别的编剧——一个陌生人被雇来代替罗布，那我早就被彻底排除在创作过程之外了。
I kept reminding myself of this.
我不断地提醒自己这一点。
Like a mantra, it's better that it's Rob.
就像念咒语一样：是罗布来写总归要好一些。
But was it?
真的是这样吗？
There were times staring down the hall at Rob's closed office door, hearing the clickety clack of his keyboard.
有时我盯着走廊那头罗布紧闭的办公室门，听着键盘的啪啪敲击声。
Was that the delete key?
那是删除键的声音吗？
Was he deleting?
他在删内容吗？
When I wished it was literally anyone in the world, but him, some writer far away.
那时我多么希望门后坐的是世界上任何其他人，而不是他，哪怕是个远在天边的作家。
Australia, Thailand, the North fucking pole.
澳大利亚、泰国、该死的北极。
anywhere but down that long, echoing hallway.
去哪儿都行，只要不是在那条长长的、回音阵阵的走廊尽头。
Even worse, news of the nascent film project had broken and now everyone was writing me.
更糟糕的是，这部电影项目初现雏形的消息已经走漏，现在所有人都在给我发信息。
Congrats, are you psyched?
“恭喜啊，你兴奋吗？”
Some days, I was sure I could hear my book screaming behind that door.
有些日子，我确信自己能听到我的书在那扇门后尖叫。
Not enough anesthesia had been administered before surgery and she'd woken up, screaming, mid incision.
手术前麻醉没打够，结果她在开刀开到一半时醒了过来，放声尖叫。
I became hyper aware that 300 pages of book could not possibly fit into 110 pages of screenplay.
我高度意识到，300页的书根本不可能塞进110页的剧本里。
So which limbs were being amputated?
那么，究竟是哪些四肢被截去了呢？
I could see my book's blood leaking out from under Rob's office door, the flesh of my life story dropping to the indifferent floor of the Abattoir, the guiltless butcher death to its cries for mercy.
我能看到我的书的鲜血从罗布的办公室门缝下流出来，我人生故事的血肉落在了屠宰场冷漠的地板上，那个毫无负罪感的屠夫对它的求饶声充耳不闻。
And then finally, the stone cold silence of death.
然后，最终迎来了死亡那般冰冷的死寂。
Rob, man, it felt so great to be writing again.
罗布，老兄，重新开始写作的感觉真是太棒了。
Having a deadline, a bullseye to hit, a raison d'etre, Paige was happy too, I could tell.
有了截稿日期、有了要命中的靶心、有了生存的意义，佩姬也很高兴，我看得出来。
Interested in my progress, very supportive.
她对我的进展很感兴趣，也非常支持。
She was relieved this had stayed in the family, rather than being outsourced to some hack she'd never met.
她很庆幸这件事留在了家里，而不是外包给某个她从未见过的文人墨客。
That would have been a nightmare.
那才真是一场噩梦。
Plus, if this movie came out great, with my name in the credits, career back on track.
另外，如果这部电影大获成功，演职员表里写着我的名字，我的职业生涯就能重回正轨。
The script was flowing too.
剧本的进展也很顺利。
It was writing itself.
简直文思泉涌。
This is what I always tell younger writers, what I was trying to teach my college students.
这就是我经常对年轻作家说的话，也是我试图教导我的大学学生的话。
absurdly, I still had months left of that charade.
荒谬的是，我还要在那种假象中度过几个月。
Writing doesn't have to be hard.
写作其实并不难。
If you're writing a script you believe in with a clear story and well-defined characters, it should feel easy.
如果你在写一个你深信不疑的剧本，有着清晰的故事和定义明确的角色，那应该感觉很简单。
It should flow.
它应该顺畅地流淌出来。
Right now, I was in that pocket.
此刻，我就处在那种游刃有余的状态中。
And as a writer, that's about as close to heaven as it gets.
作为一名作家，这几乎就是人间天堂了。
age.
佩姬。
Those weeks were a living hell.
那几个星期简直是人间地狱。
My stomach hurt nonstop.
我的胃痛得一刻也没停过。
Okay, that was a little taste of the book, the audio book, I should say.
好了，刚才那只是这本书的一小部分试听，应该说是有声书。
There are two other characters whose voices you also hear in the story.
故事中还有另外两个角色的声音。
And I'm so excited about this book.
我对这本书感到无比兴奋。
It comes out November 4 from HarperCollins and the book and the audio book are all available that day.
它将于11月4日由哈珀柯林斯出版，书和有声书都将在那一天上市。
It means the world to me.
这对我有非凡的意义。
It's my favorite thing I've written except for or Hymium, or in addition to Hymium.
这是我写过的最喜欢的东西，除了《老爸老妈浪漫史》，或者说是在《老爸老妈浪漫史》之外。
And yeah, I would love it if Hymium fans and Hymium fans would give it a read and or listen.
是的，如果《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们能去读一读或者听一听，我会非常高兴。